Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 56. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe. Und ja, heute hat mich der Weg mal wieder nach Köln geführt, aber nicht wie man vielleicht dann glauben möchte auf das große, also schon auf das DLR-Gelände, aber nicht zum DLR, denn hier, wie vielleicht manche auch wissen, die ja etwas aufmerksamer zugehört haben, gibt es auch noch einen besonderen Bereich, nämlich das Astronautenausbildungszentrum. Und das hat sehr viel mehr mit der ESA zu tun. Und heute wollen wir aber nicht über Astronauten sprechen, sondern so ein bisschen, womit die Astronauten eigentlich so beschäftigt sind. Ganz konkret möchten wir sprechen über Forschung, und zwar Forschung, die gemacht wird auf der Internationalen Raumstation, auf der ISS und als Gesprächspartner für dieses Thema. Begrüße ich Martin, Martin Zell. Hallo. Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist eingebunden in das ISS-Projekt von der ESA her. Da gehen wir gleich drauf ein. Was mich mal erstmal interessieren würde, ist, du bist ja auch schon wahrscheinlich ein bisschen länger dabei. Was war denn dein Weg in die Raumfahrt?
Ich habe nach meinem Studium, traditionelles Maschinenbau-Studium an der Universität, schon mit der Raumfahrt-Experimenten begonnen. Zuerst als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter, Experimente auf vielen Forschungsraketen gemacht und auch Spacelab-Experimente zu der Zeit entwickelt und die von meinen Kollegen unterstützt.
Spacelab war was?
Das war die wissenschaftliche Mission an Bord vom Space Shuttle, die mit der ersten Mission vor ca. im November, während es 30 Jahre war, die First Spacelab Mission, auf der auch Ulf Merwold das erste Mal geflogen ist, begonnen haben. Es gab die D1, D2-Missionen, national und natürlich viele internationale Missionen zusammen mit NASA, die bis 1998 gelaufen sind. An die Spacelab-Missionen hat sich dann das Raumstationsprogramm angeschlossen mit dem Aufbau der Raumstation Ende des letzten Jahrtausends und dem Beginn des Betriebs.
Und damit warst du schon verbunden?
Damit war ich damals schon quasi verbunden. Ich bin Ende der 80er Jahre damals noch zu Dornier gegangen, was dann danach da sah, war Astrium und hab dort Payloads gebaut im Wesentlichen für Spacelab, für die Fluidphysik, für die Materialforschung, wo wir dann natürlich auch im Missionsbetrieb eingebunden waren, zusammen mit den NASA, das waren kooperative Missionen, in den 90er Jahren und danach dann natürlich die Entwicklung der Raumstationsanlagen. Und schlussendlich bin ich seit 2003 bei der ESA in Nordwijk, zwischen Amsterdam und Den Haag. Bei der Estec. Ja, und dort zuständig für die Raumstationsnutzung und seit ca. zwei Jahren hier auch am Europäischen Astronautenzentrum für das Astronautentraining und den medizinischen Support für die Astronauten.
Aber wie bist du denn überhaupt auf den Film gekommen, in den Raumfahrt zu gehen?
Es war im Wesentlichen die Forschung und die Technik, die mich dazu geführt hat. Einfach das Experimentieren unter sehr speziellen Laborbedingungen. Weglassen oder hinzufügen von gewissen Parametern. Also weglassen ist mehr die Modulation der Schwerkraft. Das hinzufügen ist für manche Probleme die kosmische Strahlung. Und natürlich das Vakuum, was wir auch haben auf der ISS. Oder spezielle Beobachtungsbedingungen, die dort gegeben sind durch den Orbit, durch die auch relativ niedrige ÖI.
Du bist aber schon immer wieder in der Jetztzeit. Ich wollte mal so ein bisschen auf den Ursprung kommen, also ich meine, man muss ja überhaupt erst mal auf den Punkt kommen, sich in diesen Bereich überhaupt engagieren zu wollen. Also war das von Anfang an dein Ziel, schon mit der Ausbildung in die Raumfahrt zu gehen?
Eigentlich nein, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Deswegen auch das relativ traditionelle Maschinenbaustudium. Ich habe nicht Fachrichtung Luft- und Raumfahrt studiert, sondern wirklich klassischen Maschinenbau, Konstruktion und Entwicklung, wo eigentlich alles enthalten war, aber keine orbitalen Flugbahnen und diese Sachen. Aber ich habe immer sehr viel Spaß an der Kombination aus Entwicklungsaktivitäten, das heißt Ingenieursaktivitäten und Wissenschaft gehabt. Und dadurch durch die Entwicklung von solchen Anlagen oder Experimente für Wissenschaftler damals natürlich, nach meiner eigenen wissenschaftlichen Karriere an der Uni, das hat immer sehr viel Spaß gemacht, dies zu optimieren. Denn die wissenschaftlichen Requirements mit den technischen Randbedingungen von der Mission oder auch von Sicherheitsaspekten, dies alles unter einen Hut zu bringen und versuchen das auch im Rahmen natürlich der finanziellen und zeitlichen Randbedingungen, das optimale Gerät daraus zu machen, mit dem die Wissenschaft den letzten Endes möglichst viel anfangen kann. Und es war natürlich auch immer das Interesse, was kommt daraus dabei?
Also bist du sozusagen gar nicht so sehr ein Wissenschaftler selber vom Herzen, sondern mehr so ein Wissenschaftslogistiker?
Im Prinzip, gut, man hat seine Promotionszeit, wo ich selber Experimente in der Fluid-Physik, also CD-Vorgänge unter Schwerelosigkeit, untersucht habe. Dies im Wesentlichen damals, das war Mitte der 80er-Jahre noch, auf Höhenforschungsraketten, also Kurzzeitmissionen. Aber dann ist natürlich die Frage, bleibt man ewig an der Uni und macht einfach immer weiter auf dem Gebiet oder andere Dinge, gegebenenfalls, oder geht dann in die Industrie? Für mich war es relativ klar, es wird in die Industrie sein. Aber etwas, was sehr, sehr wissenschaftsnah ist, wo man Technik und Wissenschaft miteinander verbinden kann und die Herausforderung hat, möglichst viel für die Wissenschaft zu tun, neue Dinge zu realisieren. Und was natürlich interessant ist, es sind praktisch alles Prototypen, die dort gebraucht werden. Es ist keine Serienfertigung, und das natürlich auch mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen. Und das ist natürlich auch das Interessante. Und vor allem, wenn man nicht nur den Prototyp entwickelt, baut, testet, sondern auch betreiben kann. Mit dem Wissenschaftler direkt neben sich, oder wo der Wissenschaftler sagt, mach du die Sache mit dem Joystick, um es jetzt mal plakativ zu sagen.
Also sozusagen die wissenschaftliche Tätigkeit zu begleiten, das ist schon so ein langes Steckenpferd gewesen.
Absolut. Und das ist heute nach wie vor, nach praktisch 30 Jahren, immer noch spannend. Die wissenschaftlichen Ziele sind immer neu, immer anders. Und es ist auch nie das gleiche. Das schreitet immer weiter fort. Die diagnostischen Methoden werden immer besser, immer feiner, immer ausgefuchster irgendwo. Natürlich damit auch die Geräte komplizierter. Und da die richtige Balance zu finden, natürlich auch in Verbindung mit den finanziellen Ressourcen, mit der Zuverlässigkeit der Geräte, mit der Handhabbarkeit, Fernsteuerbarkeit vom Boden aus oder die Bedienung der Astronauten. Das ist so ein bisschen die Herausforderung, die unter einen Hut zu bringen.
So, jetzt bist du bei der ESA. Primär bist du sozusagen mal hier, mal in Holland, an Panels zwischen Estec und Köln hin und her, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Das ist richtig und dann kommt natürlich noch ein großer internationaler Aspekt dazu. Es ist ja nicht nur die ESA alleine, die da auf der Raumstation irgendwas tut, sondern in der Kooperation, der internationalen Kooperation mit allen möglichen Partnern, USA, im Westen, Kanada, um mal wirklich West-Ost zu gehen und dann Russland, Japan und hier gibt es natürlich nicht viele Gemeinsamkeiten. Es ist gemeinsame Forschungsziele, aber auch rein technisch. Der Aufbau der Raumstation, die Zusammensetzung, die Nutzung der verschiedenen Module und natürlich auch die damit verbundenen Ressourcen von der Crew, von den Astronauten, vom Transport, von der Akkumulation, von einzelnen Experimenten oder Anlagen. Das ist also ein sehr, sehr internationales Szenario, was natürlich sehr, sehr interessant ist, aber natürlich auch mit mancherlei Problemen behaftet ist das.
Und was ist jetzt sozusagen deine offizielle Aufgabenbeschreibung? Also was steht auf der Visitenkarte? Was ist sozusagen die Definition dessen, was du tust?
Ich bin zuständig als Leiter der Nutzung für die Raumstation und dass Astronauten Training und Medical Support auf gut Englisch heißt, das ist Head of ISS Utilization and Astronaut Support Department. Wobei die ISS Utilization Geschichte bei ASTEC stattfindet und Astronaut Support, das heißt Training und Medical, hier am ERC in Köln. Das heißt, ich glaube die ERC-Sache ist damit relativ klar, die ISS Nutzung ist folgendermaßen, ich bin zuständig für das europäische Programm, das Nutzungsprogramm, angefangen von den wissenschaftlichen Ausschreibungen, wo wir Forschungsmöglichkeiten anbieten, über die Umsetzung, das heißt die Entwicklung von Experimenten von ganzen Anlagen, die man für gewisse Experimente braucht, mal mehr, mal weniger, und natürlich das Testen und für den wissenschaftlichen Betrieb von diesen Anlagen, also praktisch von Anfang bis Ende des Nutzungsprogramms auf der Internationalen Raumstation.
Also, um es noch mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen und auch vielleicht noch mal den Leuten irgendwie klarzumachen, die das bisher noch nicht so ganz so realisiert haben, weil ich treffe auch selber immer wieder oft Leute, die das so gar nicht auf dem Zeiger haben. Da fliegt eine Raumstation um unsere Erde herum, so und die wird rund um die Uhr bespielt. Und vor allem, sie fliegt da sozusagen nicht nur herum, weil es so schön ist, eine Raumstation zu haben. Das ist natürlich auch schön so. Sondern sie wird eben auch ganz konkret genutzt. Und der primäre Nutzen dieser Raumstation ist genau diese Forschung. Also es ist kein Selbstzweck, mal auszutesten, dass man irgendwie eine Raumstation fliegen lassen kann. Sondern das ganze Ding ist von vornherein für Forschung gebaut. Und das ist 99 Prozent der Aktivität, würde ich sagen. Wenn nicht gerade Musikvideos aufgenommen werden oder was repariert werden muss.
Das wäre der Idealzustand, 90 Prozent. Ich hab hochgegriffen. Nein, natürlich die Raumstation ist ein riesen, auch auf gut neudeutschen Vehikel, nennt sich wirklich Vehicle. Es gibt auch das Vehicle Office bei der NASA dafür, die natürlich dauernd auch im Prinzip bedient gewartet werden muss, sodass also ungefähr zwei Drittel der Crewzeit für diese Aufgaben eingesetzt werden.
Zwei Drittel für Maintenance?
Um die ISS wirklich zu betreiben, Maintenance zu machen. Ungefähr ein Drittel, ein bisschen mehr als ein Drittel inzwischen, nachdem der Aufbau der Raumstation praktisch komplett ist, wird für die Forschung eingesetzt. Das lässt sich in Zahlen übersetzen. Heutzutage hat man pro Woche zwischen 35 und 45 Stunden Astronautenzeit für die Forschung auf drei Astronauten bezogen. Und die wöchentliche Arbeitszeit eines Astronauten sind gut 30 Stunden. Das heißt, auch praktisch ihre ganzen Fitnessübungen fallen praktisch auch in die Arbeitszeit rein. Die braucht pro Tag mit 1,5 bis 2 Stunden zu buchgeschlagen.
Also geht gar nicht mehr nur um den Maintenance der ISS, sondern es geht auch um die Maintenance der Astronauten selber.
Astronauten und deren Fitness und Gesunderhaltung, ganz klar. Und diese 35 bis 45 Stunden richtet sich ein bisschen, je nachdem was anwählt, ob neue Crew ankommt oder ausgetauscht wird oder ob ein Cargovehikel ankommt. Das ist so ein bisschen die Bandbreite. Die bezieht sich also auf drei Crew. Das heißt, die russische Seite hat nochmal die gleichen Ressourcen im Prinzip. Und das ist auch ein quasi ein separates Planungsspektrum. Das heißt, NASA, Canada, ESA und JAXA, das sind die Japaner, planen praktisch einen Ressourcen-Composite zusammen. Und die Russen haben praktisch die zweite Hälfte. Und die Russen stellen ja auch immer die Hälfte der ISS-Besatzung. Es sind immer drei Russen und drei andere von den anderen vier Partnern.
Ja, der Beitrag der Russen kann da nicht gering genug eingeschätzt werden. Warum das so ist, das wird einem auch schnell klar, wenn man da auf die Geschichte blickt. Dann kann ich auch nochmal kurz hier in die Geschichte von Raumzeit reinblicken. Denn ich habe ja schon einmal hier über Raumstationen gesprochen. Und zwar mit niemand geringeren als mit Reinhold Ewald. In der zehnten Ausgabe von Raumzeit war das hier das Thema. Und da haben wir natürlich auch über die ISS gesprochen, aber wir haben auch viel gesprochen über die gesamte Entwicklung. Und während ja die Amerikaner sich viel mit dem Mond auseinandergesetzt haben und auch mit anderen Missionen, die Russen ja relativ früh auf dieses Raumstationskonzept haben sich darauf konzentriert, war ja auch sehr erfolgreich mit mehreren kleineren Modulen, die über die Jahre betrieben wurden und hatten dann quasi mit der MIR die erste wirklich größere Langzeitmission mit drin. Da war ja Reinhold Ewald dann auch als deutscher Astronaut an Bord. Ja, und dann kam es zur ISS, die insofern wirklich was Besonderes ist, wie das I im Namen schon aussagt. Diese internationale Kooperation hat ja im Prinzip auch in der ganzen Raumfahrt so ein neues Zeitalter eingeläutet, finde ich. Also dass einfach dieser alte Wettstreit der Nationen sich eigentlich mehr in so einen Kooperationsding umgewandelt hat.
Würde ich absolut auch so sehen, auch mit vielen Vorteilen, denke ich, sich auch mit gewissen Problemen. Ich glaube, man kann auch sagen, der zeitlich gesehenste, der zweite Teil der MIR war eigentlich schon die Vorstufe von diesem Kooperationsprojekt, wo es dann auch Shuttle to MIR gab und die Kooperation mit den Amerikanern. Es sind viele nicht russische Astronauten auf dem MIR gewesen. Wie schon gesagt, vorhin Reinhold Ewald, Thomas Reiter. Auch für Langzeitmissionen. Das hat dann auch letzten Jahres geführt. Und auf dem MIR wurde natürlich viel Technik, Langzeittechnik, nicht nur getestet, sondern wirklich benutzt, auch langzeitmäßig. Und vieles von der MIR-Technik ist natürlich in der einen oder anderen, teilweise auch abgewandelten Form, immer noch auf der Raumstation präsent, vor allem im russischen Segment. Und insofern sind auch gewisse konzeptionelle Unterschiede, abgesehen von der äußeren Form der Module, die ein bisschen unterschiedlich sind zwischen dem US-Teil und dem russischen Teil. Aber natürlich auch innen die Technik, wo die Russen im Prinzip noch das total integrierte Konzept haben, das natürlich nicht so wahrtungsfreundlich ist. Und auf der westlichen Seite das mehr modulare System, wo man gewisse Dinge einfach austauschen kann, wie jetzt gerade letzte Woche in Kolumbus, die die zweite Wasserpumpe ausgetauscht wurde. Was eine relativ einfache Aktion war, natürlich immer mit gewissen kleineren Problemen, aber was auch problemlos geklappt hat, mit Standard-Schnittstellen und so weiter.
Die hat geleckt, das Wasser ausgetreten.
Ja, und wir haben keine Redundanz mehr gehabt. Wir haben Kolumbus die letzten paar Monate nur mit einer Pumpe betrieben. Aber das ist damit wieder revidiert. Und wir haben wieder ein vollkommen redundantes System. Und das ist natürlich auch wichtig, dieser Aspekt, um so eine Langzeit-Orbitalstation am Leben zu erhalten und auch attraktiv zu halten für die Wissenschaftler, weil die Rechner, die alten Rechner sind natürlich rein von der Performance nicht gerade berauschend. Und jeder Wissenschaftler hat in seinem Labor etwas Besseres, als es auf der Raumstation gibt. Insofern muss man da gewisse Standardschnittstellen haben, um auch die nächste oder übernächste Generation von Equipment hier einzubauen. Sei es die Rechner oder Pumpen oder Power-Module oder diverse Dinge, die halt letztendlich einfach austauschbar sind, ohne dass man das ganze Teil praktisch austauscht und ein neues hochbringt. Und es ist ja auch so, nachdem jetzt der Shuttle nicht mehr fliegt, wird natürlich auch die Anzahl der neuen REX beschränkt durch die Transmordmöglichkeiten im japanischen Vehikel, HDV, das bis auf weiteres ja noch fliegt und dort auch REX transportiert.
Warum ist das jetzt nur von dem japanischen Vehikel beschränkt? Es gibt ja noch das ATV oder passen da gar keine REX rein?
Da sind zwar im ATV sind REX drin, auch größermäßig vergleichbar, aber diese sind fest einbaut. Das sind im Prinzip wirklich Art Regale, im Prinzip, wo man Cargo transportieren kann, wo Cargo entsprechend so reingeschoben werden kann und natürlich dann entsprechend fixiert wird. Währenddessen und auch das Hatch, also die Öffnung zwischen ATV und dem russischen Segment, die ist ungefähr 70 cm, würde man keinen REX durchbringen, rein von der Dimension.
Und das japanische Modul wird mit dem...
Das wird zum einen vorne an der Vorderseite der ISS angedockt, im Prinzip an dem Knoten 2, der in der Mitte zwischen dem Columbus-Modul und dem Kibo-Modul, der Japaner ist. Entweder obendrauf oder unten hin. Oder sogar von vorne, wo ein Shuttle immer angedockt hat. Und dort ist halt dieses große, quadratische Hatch. Wo man damit auch keinen REX ausladen kann. Und natürlich wieder einladen, wenn man diesen entsorgen wollte.
Also die Raumstation ist auch so in sich, so ein bisschen auch so ein Wettstreit der Systeme. Weil es sehr viele unterschiedliche Standards gibt. Und je nachdem aus welchem Loch man rausguckt.
Es ist ein gewisser Wettstreit der Systeme. Aber es ist einfach, manches auch, würde ich sagen, historisch gewachsen. Man hat vor allem im russischen Teil gewisse Bestandteile, der damaligen MIR-Technik übernommen und natürlich entsprechend weiterentwickelt. Aber es ist trotz alledem fantastisch, weil es passt sehr vieles zusammen. Also es ist nicht alles uniform, aber die Powerversorgung passt zusammen. Das Datenpustsystem ist in vielen Fällen gleich oder ähnlich oder kompatibel zumindest.
Nur das Wasser ist unterschiedlich zwischen dem russischen und dem amerikanischen Teil, meine ich, mich noch erinnern zu können aus dem letzten Gespräch mit Reinhold Ewald.
Ich glaube, es ist mir nicht tatsächlich bewusst, dass es unterschiedlich ist, auch ATV bringt ja Wasser, das durchs russische Segmenten letztendlich transferiert wird. Aber die Kreisläufe sind separat? Die Kühlkreisläufe sind separat, das ist richtig, während die Stromversorgung im Prinzip ein großes System ist, das von den vier großen Solarpanel-Arrays gespeist wird, die auf dem Trust angebracht sind. Somit versorgt also der US-Teil im Prinzip auch den russischen Teil mit Power, mit den viermal 20 Kilowatt, die dort generiert werden.
Bevor wir vielleicht mal ganz konkret dann auch auf die Wissenschaft selbst kommen, die jetzt so dort gemacht wird, vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen der organisatorische Rahmen nochmal vorneweg. Also ISS ist ein internationales Projekt. Es gibt ein europäisches Modul, das Columbus-Modul, es gibt ein japanisches Modul. Teilweise wird das dann wieder in solchen Clustern gemeinsam verwaltet, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Das ist quasi für alles außer dem russischen Teil zuständig, was die Forschung betrifft.
Wobei, selbst da gibt es keine Differenzierung. Wir machen also durchaus, auch in früheren Jahren, bevor wir Columbus oben hatten, das Labor, seit 2008 hatten wir viele Experimente im russischen Teil der Raumstation gemacht. Und haben auch jetzt wieder ein größeres Frame Agreement, also ein Rahmenabkommen, gemeinsame Experimente mit den Russen zu machen, die teilweise schon laufen. Also wir haben ungefähr mit den Russen 30 gemeinsame Forschungsprojekte momentan identifiziert oder schon wirklich unterwegs.
Ja, aber wie verteilt sich denn dann auch so die finanzielle Last auf die einzelnen Teilnehmer? Also das ist ja alles nicht ganz billig so. Und wenn jetzt alles so irgendwie überkreuzet, dann verliebt man dann nicht komplett den Überblick.
Das ist sicherlich richtig. Also es gibt vielleicht keine harte Trennung zwischen dem russischen und dem US-Teil. Ich nenne es jetzt immer mal US-Teil, der NASA, CSI, JAXA und ESA umfasst. Das ist, sagen wir mal, pauschal 50-50. Die Russen kümmern sich um ihren Teil selbst. Das heißt mit dem Crew-Transport, mit dem Cargo-Transport, via ProGas-Vehikel und gut, sie haben im Prinzip permanent die Hälfte der Crew. Wenn man sich jetzt mal mit dem westlichen Teil beschäftigt, und das ist im Prinzip das Abkommen, die Memorandum auf Understanding, da hat NASA ca. 75% der Raumstation als größter von den westlichen Partner. Dann die JAXA, das heißt die Japaner 12,8%, ESA 8,3% und die Kanadier 2,3%. Und diese Zahlen, dieses Verhältnis teilt sich sowohl in die Pflichten, das heißt die Bringschuld, und aber auch in die Möglichkeiten, dort gewisse Dinge zu tun, zu experimentieren. Den Teil von der Crewzeit, den man bekommt, den Teil des Transports, den man bekommt, teilt sich entsprechend so auf. Das heißt, um jetzt mal vielleicht den europäischen Teil zu beschreiben, wir haben unser Columbus-Labor oben seit gut fünf Jahren. Im Februar waren es fünf Jahre. Seit damit, im Februar 2008, haben praktisch die Pflichten der ESA auch begonnen. Und das heißt, wir müssen die sogenannten Common-System-Operations-Kost bezahlen oder erbringen. Das heißt, im Immobilien-Sinn wird man es Nebenkosten nennen, die allerdings bei der Raumstation etwas substanzeller sind. Die ESA macht es so über die ATVs, also die Automated Transfer Vehicles, wo jetzt momentan seit circa einem Monat ATV 4 angedockt ist.
Bei den Einstein-Missionen.
Genau. Und 6,5 Kilo Cargo auf der Raumstation. Cargo verschiedener Sorten, also das sogenannte Dry Cargo, was in diesen Racks ist, der natürlich Treibstoff, Wasser, Gas abgeliefert hat. Und diese, ich nenne es jetzt mal pauschal, 6,5 Tonnen pro Vehikel, oder es können auch bis zu 7 sein, werden uns als Kredit im Prinzip angerechnet zu einem gewissen Konversationsfaktor. Und damit bezahlen wir quasi in kind, das heißt mit Transportleistung den wesentlichen Teil unseres Raumstationsbeitrags. Und deswegen müssen wir als ESA in gewissen Abständen ein ATV fliegen, um dies entsprechend zu tun. In der Zukunft wird dies das Service-Modul für das MPCV sein, mit dem wir dann den Rest unserer Bringschuld bis 2020 bezahlen und danach wird man entsprechend sehen.
Auf Basis der ATV-Technologie wird ein Modul gebaut, was dann auch für Astronauten gedacht wird, was für den USA eingesetzt wird mit der neuen Generation.
Genau, aber was eigentlich nichts mit der Raumstation zu tun hat, das ist also für jenseits von Low Earth Orbit gedacht. Und das ist dann im Prinzip die Zukunft. Und dann gibt es noch einen kleinen Teil, den die ESA auch bezahlen muss, also für Telekommunikation und solche Kosten. Und natürlich den eigenen Aufwand, das heißt, um das Columbus Control Zentrum zu bedienen oder zu betreiben, das ATV Control Zentrum, die User Support and Operations Centers, wo also die Experimente betrieben werden, typisch europäisch, neun dezentrale Zentren für die Nutzung in verschiedenen Ländern. Und natürlich auch der Engineering Support, das heißt, der sogenannte Industrial Operator, das Industrial Operator Team geführt von Astrium und Thales Alenia in Italien und vielen anderen Firmen als Unterauftragnehmer, die sich natürlich um die Technik kümmern, die sie teilweise oder größtenteils auch entwickelt haben. Und natürlich jetzt in den ganzen Jahren sich um den technischen Support, um die Problembeseitigung und natürlich auch um die Evolution des Equipments on Orbit kümmern.
An der Stelle nochmal kurz zwei Verweise auf vorangegangene Gespräche, die jetzt hier vielleicht auch relevant sein könnten für jeden, der das noch nicht gehört hat. In der 17. Ausgabe habe ich mit Nico Dettmann gesprochen, zuständig fürs ATV, natürlich über das ATV. Also, sich mal da einen Einblick geben lassen sollen. Die faszinierende Technik dieses Moduls, wirklich beeindruckend. Dieser vollautomatische Anflug an die ISS hat ja auch, sagen wir mal, den Rest der Raumfahrtwelt dann doch ganz gut beeindruckt. Und ja, das Columbus-Modul wird ja dann auch vor allem von Oberpfaffenhofen aus, vom Deutschen Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum permanent überwacht und dort kommuniziert. Das Ausgabe 36 zu dem Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum. Ja, aber jetzt kommen wir doch nochmal genauer auf die Wissenschaft. Also, ich habe natürlich ein bisschen übertrieben mit den 99 Prozent, aber es ist natürlich klar, darum geht es vor allem. Das ist der primäre Nutzen, den auch alle daraus ziehen und ziehen sollen. Und jetzt muss ja diese Wissenschaft in irgendeiner Form auch organisiert werden, weil es ja nicht so, dass sich jeder mal gerade ausdenken kann, so ach, ISS wollte schon immer was reinschieben ins REC. So einfach ist es nicht. Stellt sich die Frage, was ist der Weg für einen Wissenschaftler in die Raumstation? Also zunächst einmal für welche Bereiche ist das überhaupt interessant? Wer will da eigentlich hoch? Und wenn das dann gewollt ist, wie macht man es?
Das ist sicherlich ein wichtiger Faktor. Diese generelle Setup oder die Organisation, wie die ISS-Nutzung quasi läuft. Ich fange jetzt mal ganz am Anfang an, wirklich mit der Ausschreibung von Fluggelegenheiten, von Experimentiergelegenheiten, die die ESA alle paar Jahre macht. Wir bereiten gerade das nächste Research Announcement vor, das Ende des Jahres dann publiziert wird. Das ist ein internationales Research Announcement zusammen mit allen Raumstationspartnern.
Was heißt Research Announcement?
Also eine Forschungs-Ankündigung oder eine Forschungsgelegenheit.
Das heißt, es wird sozusagen ausgeschrieben?
Ja, es wird ausgeschrieben. Wir sagen dann, okay, in diesem Zeitraum gibt es diese Randbedingungen auf der Raumstation. Es gibt diese gerätetechnischen Voraussetzungen.
Die Zeit in die Zukunft, reicht das?
Wir haben momentan in unserem Pool Experimente. Dies wurden weitgehend 2010 selektiert. Das waren die letzten beiden großen Ausschreibungen. Die werden die letzten ungefähr 2016, 2017 abgearbeitet sein. Die etwas komplexeren in dem Fall, für die eine Menge Hardware-Entwicklung notwendig war.
Aber wenn sie 2010 ausgewählt wurden, dann müssen ja auch schon vorher dieses Announcement dafür rausgegangen sein.
Das Announcement geht praktisch ein halbes Jahr vorher raus. Also die Wissenschaftler haben ungefähr ein halbes Jahr Zeit, sich dazu zu helfen. Ein halbes Jahr, fünf Monate ungefähr Zeit, auf diese Ausschreibung zu reagieren, ihre Proposals zu schreiben. Und die werden dann entsprechend von Gutachtern, also neutralen Gutachtern evaluiert. Und auch quasi mit einer gewissen Punktezahl versehen. Maximal 100.
Und das findet am STEC statt?
Das wird von STEC organisiert. Also wir sind auch nicht die Wissenschaftler an sich. Wir nehmen auch da nicht teil an diesen Ausschreibungen. Wir organisieren die Ausschreibung. Und wir setzen dann die entsprechenden selektierten Proposals um. Das heißt, wir schauen, dass die Ziele mit den Randbedingungen, die auf der Raumstation herrschen, Grozheit, Sicherheit und all die Dinge, kompatibel sind. Bauen wo nötig auch die entsprechende Hardware dazu. Und versuchen die natürlich mit den wissenschaftlichen Zielen per se in Einklang zu bringen. Die neue Ausschreibung, die jetzt Ende des Jahres kommen wird, die dreht sich vor allem um die Lebenswissenschaft, das heißt um die medizinischen Forschungen und um die Biologie. Und diese Experimente, die dann Ende 2014 ausgewählt werden, die werden größtens bis 2020 ungefähr abgearbeitet werden. Sodass sich da quasi ein kontinuierliches Spektrum von früher ausgewählten oder neu ausgewählten Experimenten ergibt, ohne dass es dort jetzt eine ganz strikte Rangfolge gibt, was zuerst war und was dann zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt gemacht werden soll. Dies richtet sich dann mehr nach den Randbedingungen. Ist die Hardware verfügbar, muss sie erst entwickelt werden. Es ist ein sehr co-intensives Experiment, muss es vielleicht von irgendwelchen externen Konstellationen gewisse Dinge einhalten, wie jetzt Sonnenzyklus oder sowas, was man beobachten will. Aber meistens ist es mehr durch die Ressourcenrandbedingungen getrieben. Das heißt, Experiment Hardware ist die verfügbar. Können wir es vor allem im medizinischen Bereich, wo man sehr viel Crewzeit braucht, um die Experimente zu machen, können wir dies durchführen, beziehungsweise man muss dies dann entsprechend staffeln, dass man dies mit den Limitierungen in Einklang bringt. Und natürlich, was sicher auch jetzt in der Übergangsphase zwischen Shuttle und den neuen Vehikeln ist, ist die Proben-Transport-Logistik, die ist gegeben, vor allem die Rückführung der Proben, die jetzt wieder mit der SpaceX-Kapsel möglich ist, wo man bis zu 1,5 Tonnen von der ISS zurückbringen kann. Teilweise auch thermisch konditioniert, vor allem die sensitiven biologischen oder medizinischen Proben, die teilweise in gefrorenem Zustand zurückkommen müssen. Und natürlich auch eine ununterbrochene Kette, also Kühlkette, haben müssen. Währenddessen man nur in einer Sojus größtordnungsmäßig 50 Kilo zurückbringen kann.
Ich merke gerade, es wird heute die Sendung, die am meisten andere Sendung erwähnt, weil das alles gerade so wunderbar in den Zusammenhang passt und hier zusammenkommt. Ich hatte mich ja vor einiger Zeit schon mit Ulrike Friedrich vom DLR unterhalten, die ja für den Schwerelosigkeitsforschungsbereich zuständig ist. Primär fällt da natürlich der Parabelflug rein, wo wir sehr viel darüber gesprochen haben, was halt sozusagen überhaupt die Schwerelosigkeit an sich auch bringt. Weil das ist ja eigentlich das Ding. Es geht ja gar nicht darum, hoch zu sein, sondern es ist einfach die Abwesenheit des unmittelbaren Einflusses der Gravitation, der eben für diese Projekte relevant ist. Sollten wir vielleicht auch gleich nochmal ein bisschen darüber reden, welche Bereiche das jetzt hier auf der ISS primär tangiert. Aber jetzt gerade bei dieser Auswahl fiel mir dann auch noch gleich ein anderes Gespräch ein. Es gibt ja, wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, auch noch diese Höhenforschungsraketen, vor allem halt in Kiruna, die zum Einsatz kommen. Und da hatten wir hier in der 45. Ausgabe nochmal eine Betrachtung dieses Rexus-Bexus-Projekts, wo ja im Prinzip junge Wissenschaftler auch schon genau an diesen Modus herangebracht werden. Wir wollen jetzt mal was machen und dort quasi so im Schnelldurchlauf, als selektiertes Projekt, eben all diese Anforderungen auch lernen, einem solchen Announcement auch das entsprechende entgegenzutragen, weil das zieht man sich ja jetzt mal nicht gerade aus dem Ärmel, zu sagen, ach ja, hier ISL ist kein Problem, ich schreib da mal ein paar Seiten zusammen, weil die Anforderungsliste ist natürlich extrem groß. Das Material muss den Startbedingungen entsprechen, muss entsprechende Sicherheitsvorkehrungen natürlich haben, um sonst nichts anderes zu gefährden etc. Das heißt, die Wissenschaftler, die letzten Endes auf so ein Announcement wirklich antworten können, müssen ja eigentlich auch eine gewisse Erfahrung haben oder zumindest auch ein bestimmtes Training genossen haben, um überhaupt erst mal an dieser Stelle auch sich melden zu können, oder?
Das ist sicher richtig. Und ich glaube, auch diese Kurzzeitmissionen sowohl im Fallturm wie auf den Parabelflügen und auch den Ballon- und Raketenflügen sind ganz hervorragend für junge Wissenschaftler, weil die sind vom Zeithorizont relativ kurzfristig. Man kann diese in einem Jahr oder ein bisschen mehr realisieren. Man kann dort auch oft die eigene Hardware sogar fliegen, muss sie teilweise selbst sogar mitbringen, weitgehend. Und kann dabei in vielerlei Hinsicht wissenschaftlich, technisch, operationell sehr, sehr viel lernen. Und das ist die ideale Einstiegsstufe letzten Endes. Währenddessen ist es sogar auf der Raumstation etwas einfacher. Man braucht dort sehr natürlich solide Ideen. Warum muss das Experiment dort sein? Ist es ein Langzeitexperiment? Habe ich so viele Parameter und so weiter? Und man muss natürlich eines betrachten. Sind die allgemeinen Randbedingungen halbwegs kompatibel? Das heißt, ist etwas hochgiftig, wird es auf der Raumstation etwas schwieriger? Ist etwas explosiv, sehr brennbar? Oder sonst solche Dinge, da wird es von der Safety her kritisch. Was auf den Raketenexperimenten viel einfacher ist und fast ohne Einschränkungen durchführbar ist. Deswegen machen wir auch in unserem Programm, dem Europäischen Programm für Life and Physical Science in Space, also das heißt Lebenswissenschaften und die Physik, machen wir solche kritischen Experimente weiterhin auf die Forschungsraketen, die eine sehr stringente Probenlogistik haben. Das heißt eine halbe Stunde vor dem Start rein in das Experimentmodul und eine Viertelstunde nach der Landung wird auch zurückgeholt ins Labor, was natürlich auf der ISS nicht geht. Das ist alles sehr viel langfristiger. Aber das Gute ist auch für Wissenschaftler, auf der ISS, sie brauchen, zumindest bei der ESA, ihr Experiment nicht alleine bauen. Sie können sich wirklich auf die Wissenschaft fokussieren. Die Raumfahrtindustrie baut diese Experimente entsprechend den Requirements, also den Anforderungen von den Wissenschaftlern. Und testet auch die und macht all das, die oftmals sehr schwierige Arbeit, vor allem wenn man die ganzen Bibeln, die auf der Raumstation als Requirements anwendbar sind, wenn man diese beachten soll. Und ich weiß noch von Spacelab-Missionen, wo Wissenschaftler eigene Experimente gebaut haben, am Schluss wird der Wissenschaftler zum Techniker und vergisst seine eigene Wissenschaft. Und ist eigentlich, wenn es losgeht, als ein erstehend K.o.
Ist denn diese Trennung so ohne Weiteres machbar? Weil ich meine, nicht selten ist ja die Forschung und das Gerät dafür dann doch sehr eng miteinander, also ist auf jeden Fall eng miteinander verheiratet.
Es ist auf alle Fälle so und es braucht schon auch auf der Industrieseite viel Erfahrung, um dort aus diesen Anforderungen ein wirklich sinnvolles und taugliches Gerät letztendlich herzustellen. Dazu geht es natürlich auch nicht, dass der Wissenschaftler nur seine Anforderungen aufschreibt, ein Blatt Papier auf den Tisch hinterlässt, dass man das der Industrie rüberreicht und die baut. Und nach ein paar Jahren kommt der Wissenschaftler wieder. Das ist also eine Interaktion. Die Wissenschaftler werden auch von uns, von S-TEC betreut, von den Wissenschaftskoordinatoren auf ESA-Seite, werden im Entwicklungsprozess für die Hardware bleiben eingebunden, sind bei den Entwicklungsreviews dabei, können also checken, entwickelt sich oder wird das entsprechend ihren Vorstellungen. Manchmal muss man auch noch ein bisschen drimmen. Das heißt, die Wissenschaftler haben manchmal auch auf halbem Weg neue Ideen, zusätzliche Ideen, sodass man dann von der Hardware-Entwicklung noch mal gegebenenfalls darauf reagiert. Und sie sind natürlich dann auch in den letzten Tests eingebunden, wenn man auch in die Anlagen geht und dort das Experiment, das Flugexperiment in der Bodenanlage, die ein Replikat der Anlage oben auf der Raumstation ist, ist dann nach mehr oder weniger allen Regeln der Kunst auch im wissenschaftlichen Sinne testet. Nicht nur einen technischen Funktionstest macht, sondern auch die wissenschaftlichen Parameter abfährt, soweit es auf der Erde durch die Schwerkraftbedingungen sinnvoll ist. Und natürlich dann, während der Betriebsphase, sitzen natürlich die Wissenschaftler entweder im USOC, das heißt den User Support and Operations Centers, oder in ihren User Homebases, was wahrscheinlich jeder weiß. Das heißt, wo sie ein Terminal in ihrem eigenen Institut, in ihrem eigenen Labor haben, wo sie die Daten kriegen, von wo sie kommandieren können. Natürlich immer durch geschleust, durch USOC und Kolumbus Control Center, rauf zur Raumstation. Und zwischendrin finden natürlich gewisse Compatibilitätschecks statt.
Es sind auch eine ganze Menge Institutionen und Schritte gefallen. Ich würde ganz gerne mal kurz zurück an den Anfang. Also, die Ausschreibung eines solchen Projektes wird dann gemacht. Man stellt also fest, okay, verschiedene Experimente laufen aus. Es wird sozusagen platzfrei oder es wird crewzeitfrei oder beides in dem Zusammenhang. Und dann sagt man, okay, alles klar, das sind hier so etwa die Slots, das sind so etwa die Zeiträume, das sind vielleicht auch schon so die Startzeiträume. Ich weiß nicht, es dürfte wahrscheinlich da an der Stelle schon alles mit eingepreist sein. Dann kriegt man jetzt diese Anträge. Ich weiß nicht, in welchen Mengen geht das so ein? Also wie viel mehr kriegt man, als man annehmen kann?
Ungefähr vielleicht über einen Daumen dreimal so viel, viermal so viel, als man tatsächlich annehmen kann. Beziehungsweise als den mehr oder weniger stringenten wissenschaftlichen Kriterien die mit denen kompatibel sind, wo man sagt, okay, das ist wissenschaftlich wertvoll. Das hat einen Bezug zu Raumfahrtbedingungen, das heißt, Schwerelosigkeit oder Strahlung oder Vakuum oder Erdbeobachtung. Irgendwas, wo man wirklich so eine Fluggelegenheit dafür braucht, um dieses Experiment nur ausschließlich dort machen zu können oder zu müssen. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch eine gewisse Punktebewertung. Eine Skala bis 100, 100 Punkte maximal. Wir haben bis maximal 70 Punkte, die Experimente ausgewählt und akzeptiert. Teilweise hatten wir auch die Grenze nochmals weiter angehoben, um einfach nicht so viele zu haben. Weil das ist auch nicht attraktiv für die Wissenschaftler, wenn man einen riesen Pool hat und den erst nach vielen Jahren abarbeiten kann. Und das ist vielleicht auch in unserem im Raumstationsprogramm etwas anderes, wie für eine Science- oder Erdbeobachtungsmission, wo man sagt, okay, das ist die Mission. Dieser Satellik fliegt dann in dem und dem Orbit oder zu jedem Planeten. Das ist genau das Ziel. Die ISS ist eine permanente Plattform, ein permanentes Labor, das für vielfältige Nutzungsmöglichkeiten natürlich zur Verfügung steht. Insofern wählen wir bei solchen Ausschreibungen mehr Experimente aus, als wir in kurzer Zeit umsetzen können. Das heißt, die Umsetzung oder Abarbeitung all dieser Experimente dauert dann durchaus drei, vier, fünf Jahre insgesamt, auch von den Ressourcen her. Aber natürlich wird nur etwas ausgewählt, was auch mit dem Labor, mit dem permanenten Labor und entsprechend natürlich dem Orbit, in dem dieses flickt oder die Randbedingungen, die man hat von der Bedienung, von der Automatisierung, von den Sicherheitsanforderungen kompatibel ist. Und all diese Experimente sind aber dann in unserem Forschungspool und werden sukzessive abgearbeitet und implementiert. Im Gegensatz zu den Satellitenmissionen, da werden nur die ausgewählt, die genau für diese Mission passen. Und natürlich auch nur begrenzte Menge, weil man kann nicht beliebig viele darauf tun. Und alle anderen werden praktisch wieder zurückgewiesen.
Okay, also es werden so Punkte vergeben und es gibt irgendeinen Threshold, der noch ein bisschen angepasst werden kann. Was sind denn jetzt sozusagen die primären Kriterien? Also abgesehen davon, okay, es ist ein Langzeitexperiment, aber es geht ja primär um Grundlagenforschung, oder? Ist das schon so das Wesentliche, was gemacht wird?
Ich denke, man muss vielleicht zwei Dinge unterscheiden. Es gibt zum einen die Forschungsthemen, die wesentlichen Forschungsgebiete, und dann noch die Differenzierung Grundlagenforschung zum einen, anwendungsorientierte oder vielleicht sogar industrielle Forschung zum anderen. Bleiben wir vielleicht einen kurzen Moment bei den wesentlichen Forschungsgebieten. Dort ist die medizinische Forschung mit verschiedenen Aspekten, Herz-Kreislauf-System, Muskel-Knochen-System, die Neurophysiologie und Immunologie. Das sind die wesentlichen Subthemen im medizinischen Bereich. Dann die Biologie, darunter fällt die Pflanzenbiologie. Die Entwicklungsbiologie, das heißt also Lebewesen, vom Ei bis zur nächsten oder mehrere Generationen, die sich oftmals im tierischen Bereich im Bereich von Wochen oder maximal Monaten abspielen. Und dann natürlich die Zell- und Molekularbiologie, die auch sehr eng mit der medizinischen Forschung verbunden ist, wo man einzelne Zellen und deren Verhalten und deren Stimulation untersucht. Oder vielleicht noch ein Aspekt, der auch noch dazugehört, ist die Astrobiologie, wo man im Prinzip im Wesentlichen versucht, wie verhalten sich Organismen im Weltraum, also im freien Weltraum unter Vakuum, UV, extremen thermischen Bedingungen, Strahlungsbeginnungen. Das heißt, können Organismen von Planet zu Planet im Prinzip den Weltraum durchfliegen, nenne ich es mal so, und sind immer noch lebensfähig, wenn sie mal woanders hankommen.
Also Fragestellungen, die sich jetzt zum Beispiel ergeben, wenn man über eine Mars-Mission nachdenkt, also bemannte Mars-Missionen.
Wir haben auf der nächsten auch wieder Proben drin, die also unter Mars-Bedingungen im Prinzip dann dem freien Weltraum ausgesetzt werden.
Wie hieß noch gleich das Experiment? Da gibt es auch diese menschenartige Puppe, die dort auf der ISS permanent der Strahlenbelastung ausgesetzt wird.
war Matroschka.
Ja, war ja wichtig, Matroschka.
Das war ein menschliches Phantom, also auch von den Gewebesimulationen, wo man an gewissen Stellen im Körper, natürlich auch im Kopf, wo gewisse Organe sitzen, Dosimeter hatte und dort die Strahlungsbelastung auch durch das Gewebe letztendlich gemessen hat. Matroschka war eine Zeit lang außerhalb der Raumstation am russischen Segment, das war noch vor Kolumbus, und dann aber auch in verschiedenen Modulen innerhalb der Raumstation im russischen Teil, auch im japanischen Labor. Matroschka ist momentan zurück am Boden, steht noch in Russland. Wird gegebenenfalls für nochmals eine weitere Mission mit neuen aktiven Dosimetern aufgerüstet und nochmals geflogen. Wir haben allerhand andere Dosimeter auf der Raumstation und bereiten auch für die Crew ein aktives Dosimeter vor, wo sie also der drahtloser Übertragung zu einem zentralen Modul auf der ISS immer ihre aktuellen Strahlungswerte sowohl innen wie auch bei Außenbord-Einsätzen kontinuierlich registrieren können. Und wir wissen ja, das ist ja kein gleichbleibendes Niveau, sondern entsprechend den Sonnenaktivitäten mal mehr, weil weniger.
Wie das Wetter gerade so ist.
Währenddessen der Unterschied zwischen innen und außen ist nicht so gravierend, also der Faktor 2 oder 3. Das ist also keine Größenordnung. Es ist nur auch ungefähr messbar, aber es schadet alles sozusagen. Richtig. Ich hatte vorhin den Bereich der Lebenswissenschaften beschrieben. In der Physik ist es im Wesentlichen die Fluidphysik. Dort gibt es ein sehr, sehr weites Spektrum. Da geht es von Diffusionsmessungen über Strömungsmessungen verschiedener Art, Simulationen, Chloride, Aggregationszustände, komplexe Plasmen, Schäume, Emulsionen. Das ist mehr der Fluidphysikbereich, der sehr, sehr weite Fluidphysikbereich, der aber auch vielfach als Simulationsmedien mit der Materialwissenschaft verbunden ist. Weil man in der Fluidphysik manche zum Beispiel Erstarungsvorgänge mit transparenten Medien bei niedrigeren Temperaturen natürlich optisch beobachten kann mit Interferometrie oder so. Und dort die Mikrostuklaurausbildung beobachten kann. Währenddessen diesen man natürlich mit metallischen Legierungen, die sind opak, die werden bei 1000 bis 1800 Grad prozessiert irgendwo, wo natürlich diese Art von Diagnostik letztendlich dann versagt, wo man aber dafür die ganze Materialprobe in einer Kartusche nach der Prozessierung wieder auf die Erde zurückbringt und dies natürlich nach allen Regeln der Kunst dann analysiert. Und abgesehen davon, im physikalischen Bereich gibt es noch die Fundamentalfysik. Das heißt, Vorgänge zum Beispiel wie Atomuhren, Bose-Einstein-Aspekte, Kanten-Kryptographie, solche Dinge. Also wird es wirklich auf mehr Phänomene im einsteinischen Bereich zurückgehen. Die macht man in der Fundamentalfysik auf der Raumstation, hängt im Wesentlichen mit der Schwerelosigkeit zusammen, weil die Vorgänge natürlich dort sehr langsam entsprechend ablaufen. Und man dadurch die Beobachtung und oder die Präzision bei diesen Prozessen deutlich verbessern kann. Also es ist eigentlich der ganze Bereich in den Lebenswissenschaften plus der Physik genau genommen. Es ist natürlich relativ wenig, was die Astrophysik betrifft, weil das ist die Raumstation vielleicht vom Orbit her nicht ganz optimal. Und natürlich Planeten, Physik und so weiter, das oder Planetmissionen finden halt woanders statt.
Ja genau, da muss man auch weiter raus. Da gibt es auch dann die spezifischen Projekte und Missionen für.
Absolut, ja. Und vielleicht noch ein Aspekt, den ich am Anfang noch geschildert habe. Und dann gibt es die Grundlagenforschung. Das heißt, die in erster Linie mal zweckfreie Forschung, wo der Wissenschaftler sagt, okay, ich sehe hier ein Problem, oder ich möchte was untersuchen, oder ich habe eine These, die ich beweisen will oder widerlegen will. Und deswegen will ich hier experimentieren. Wo man jetzt nicht unbedingt in diesem Bereich eine direkte Anwendung daraus ableiten will oder kann. Das ist mehr von der wissenschaftlichen Neugier und generellen Forschung getrieben. Und dann gibt es den anderen Bereich, das ist mehr anwendungsorientierte Forschung. Da sind oftmals auch Industriefirmen daran beteiligt, an diesen Experimenten, die mehr im physikalischen Bereich, im Materialbereich oder so stattfinden, wo aber jetzt nicht zwingend neue Materialien im Weltraum hergestellt werden, sondern mehr, die Prozesse untersucht werden, die Physik untersucht wird. Wie kann man diese manipulieren? Und es ist nicht per se alles unter Schwerelosigkeit besser. Wie man früher mal, vor 30 Jahren, gab es gewisse Leute, die gesagt haben, wir ziehen da wunderbare gigantische Einkristalle und das ist das perfekte Material. Das funktioniert zum einen nicht so gar so perfekt und zum zweiten ist es auch nicht unbedingt das perfekte Material. Wir haben durchaus gesehen, auch bei der gerichteten Erstarrung, wenn man denkt, man nimmt die Schwerkraft weg und das Ding wächst wunderbar und homogen. Es ist aber von den Materialeigenschaften oft besser, wenn man eine gewisse, wohldosierte Rührwirkung hat. Dazu nehmen wir in erster Instanz mal die Schwerkraft weg und haben dann einen magnetischen Rührer, der rührt nicht wirklich in der Probe, sondern ein Magnetfeld, das sich außerhalb der Probe befindet, aber zu einer gewissen kleinen Rührwirkung in der Probe beiträgt und damit die Materialeigenschaften optimiert. Oder man wirklich Materialeigenschaften für die Gießereitechnik misst im Weltraum und einfach die Daten nimmt und dann in entsprechende Gießereimodelle einführt und dort den Prozess besser im Griff hat. Und damit natürlich vor allem die Materialeigenschaften verbessert und natürlich, was sehr viel wichtiger ist oder genauso wichtig, den Ausschuss massiv verringert. Letztendlich, wo man ansonsten alles oder vieles dem Zufall überlässt, im gießtechnischen Sinne. Und wo man aber dort die Materialeigenschaften für die Numerik, für die Analyse oder für die Definition der Gießtechnik sehr viel besser vorbestimmen kann. Und natürlich dann auch deutlich bessere Produkte hat.
Das heißt, neben der Grundlagenforschung für bestimmte medizinische und physikalische Disziplinen ist auch dieser industrielle Bereich, der so primär in Materialforschung, Prozessoptimierung, Herstellungsunterstützung, Optimierung reinfließt, das sind so die großen Anwendungen der Wissenschaft?
Das sind die Physik-Anwendungen. In den Lebenswissenschaften ist es dann mehr in der Biotechnologie, also in der Zellbiologie und Molekularbiologie. Und dann natürlich die medizinischen Forschungen, die sich mit ganz wohlbekannten menschlich-irdischen Problemen beschäftigt, wie mit Osteoporose, mit Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen, wo man in relativ kurzer Zeit an gesunden Astronauten eine mehr oder weniger ausgeprägte Veränderung der Körperfunktionen tatsächlich feststellen kann. Und je nachdem, wie die Experimente sind, die einen Experimente messen mehr diese Veränderungen, also praktisch passiv, was passiert, wenn man es einfach so laufen lässt. Und andere Experimente versuchen dann auch, was kann ich dagegen tun? Was Vergegenmaßnahmen kann ich praktisch, während der Astronaut fliegt, unternehmen, damit die es gar nicht eintritt? Also zum Beispiel Knochenschwund oder Probleme mit Gelenken oder Bluthochdruck oder auch im neurophysiologischen Bereich, wo gewisse Dinge sich letztendlich einfach verändern, auch wo unsere Wahrnehmung sich unter den Bedingungen der Schwerelosigkeit verändert, wo es keinen oben und keinen unten mehr gibt. Und man sieht viele visuelle Eindrücke oder so sind unter anderem auch von der Schwerkraft zu einem gewissen Teil geprägt. Und das muss man letztendlich verstehen. Und hier werden natürlich auch die diagnostischen Möglichkeiten immer feiner, immer besser. Die Magnetresonanz, Tomographie und Ultraschall-Methoden, die auch auf der Raumstation dort sind, um gewissen Abständen untersuchen und zu machen, sind natürlich, geben viele Aufschlüsse, sind natürlich aber auch für die Industrie, vom apparatechnischen Instrumentarium sehr interessant.
Da kann ich ja wieder auf eine Raumzeitfolge verweisen, fällt mir gerade ein, die ich nämlich nur ein paar Meter von hier geführt habe mit Robert Gerzer vom Institut für Luft- und Raumfahrtmedizin vom DLR. Über Weltraummedizin, wo genau diese Aspekte auch nochmal genauer beleuchtet wurden. Jetzt, ich würde gern mal ein bisschen, das ist immer alles so schwierig zu greifen, weil es natürlich ein extrem vielfältiges Ding ist. Jedes Experiment ist immer wieder anders, jede Konstellation, jede Anforderung, was da gebaut und betrieben werden muss, ist immer wieder anders. Da kann man wahrscheinlich auch gleich den Überblick verlieren. Um es vielleicht mal ein bisschen plastischer zu machen, können wir vielleicht mal so ein paar Beispiele herausgreifen von so exemplarischen Projekten, die jetzt, sagen wir mal auch, wo man ganz gut ablesen kann, was das jetzt konkret bedeutet für die Wissenschaftler, sich zu bewerben, sich mit der Industrie, über den Bau entsprechenden Geräts abzustimmen, dann das Ganze zur ISS zu bekommen. Da fällt ja auch noch mit rein, auch die Astronauten müssen ja dann im Prinzip damit ausgebildet werden und mit diesen Experimenten vertraut gemacht werden, bis dann auch diese Ergebnisse wieder zurückkommen, die ja teilweise nicht nur generierte Daten sind, sondern teilweise muss man ja dann eben auch das Objekt selber zurücknehmen. Gibt es da sicherlich eine Menge nennenswerte Projekte dabei, aber gibt es auch ein paar schöne Sachen, die man mal ein bisschen genauer anschauen sollte, um zu verstehen, wie dieser Prozess so läuft?
Es ist sicherlich, ich denke mal, es gibt die vier, fünf wesentlichen Felder, die ich auch vorhin beschrieben habe, wo auch in den einzelnen Feldern die Implementierung ein bisschen unterschiedlich ist. Ich fange jetzt nochmal mit der Medizin an. Dort wird meist nicht sehr viel neues Gerät, neue Instrumente gebraucht, sondern wir haben auf der Raumstation eine Anzahl von Racks, die verschiedene Funktionen erfüllen. Das heißt Herz-Kreislauf-Sensoren, Beatmungs-Messungsgeräte, Blutzentrifugen, andere Sensoren, Neuro.
Die jetzt vor allem auch auf die Astronauten selber angewendet werden. Die Astronauten sind ja auch selber Objekt der Forschung.
Die Astronauten, die Forschungsobjekte und bei den medizinischen Experimenten braucht man je nach wissenschaftlichen Ziel minimal sechs verschiedene Astronauten oder Kosmonauten bis zu maximal 30 oder so. Es gibt natürlich im klinischen Sinne wäre das eine sehr, sehr beschränkte Statistik, aber es geht einfach wegen der Kohlezeit nicht besser. Das ist natürlich auch so, dass die Protokolle entsprechend ausgefuchst sind.
Astronauten fallen ja auch nicht vom Himmel.
Und sonst wäre ja auch die Dauer der Experimente, die würden ja über 10, 15 Jahre gehen letzten Jahres. Und wir versuchen auch diese medizinischen Experimente in zwei, drei Jahren ungefähr abzuwickeln und zu Ende zu bringen. Und damit auch eine wissenschaftliche Generation noch ihre eigenen Experimente auswerten und auch entsprechend publizieren kann.
Das Experiment soll ja die Wissenschaftliche aber nicht überleben.
Ja, und auch im medizinischen Bereich, da wird man oftmals nur ein relativ kleines Instrumentarium zusätzlich bauen werden müssen. Ein Stimulator oder ein Sensor oder sowas. Und der restliche Teil von diesen Instrumenten ist auf der Raumstation vorhanden. Und hier ist ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt im medizinischen Forschung. Dort wird praktisch wirklich alle ISS-Partner legen zusammen. Und man kann diese über alle Grenzen hinweg benutzen. Weil oft braucht man diverse Geräte, dort bis hin zu am Schluss für die Freezer, um die Proben einzulagern und zu konditionieren. Und das ist also wirklich eine sehr internationale Abwicklung. Aber auch, und deswegen auch die internationale Ausschreibung, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, internationale Forschungsteams. Also nicht nur europäisch international, sondern global international. Das erhöht natürlich gleichzeitig die Bereitschaft, dass zum Beispiel in aktuellen Fällen mit NASA und ESA-Experimenten auch diese Geräte beizusteuern und teilweise auch die Crew-Zeit natürlich dann zu teilen. 50-50 oder in gewissen Verhältnissen, um diese Experimente auch von der Crew-Zeit durchführbar zu machen. Und hier ist natürlich die NASA oder auch unsere russischen Kollegen ein sehr, sehr wertvoller Partner, weil die natürlich um ein Faktor 10 mehr Crew-Zeit insgesamt zur Verfügung haben, als die ESA hat. Und da sind natürlich diese Kooperationsmöglichkeiten äußerst wertvoll.
Aber das bedeutet, dass auch gerade diese medizinischen Experimente dann auch ganz gut von Modul zu Modul getragen werden. Also das da wirklich überall mal irgendwo was beigesteuert wird, vielleicht für ein einzelnes Experiment?
Das ist absolut richtig. Hier ein aktuelles Experiment, dass wir auch morgen zusammen mit NASA im Rahmen des Humans in Space Symposium, die wir diskutieren werden, ist im Prinzip eine Art Active Resistive Exercise Device, das ist also im Prinzip wie beim Gewichtheben eine Maschine, die mit Hydraulik und Pneumatik funktioniert, auf der Raumstation, wo sich die Astronauten betätigen können. Das ist der NASA-Beitrag gerätetechnisch. Der ESA-Beitrag ist die ganze Sensorik, das heißt die Videoauswertung. Und Erfassung der ganzen Bewegungen.
Was ist das für eine Art Sportgerät für die Astronauten?
Ganz genau. Das ist also im Prinzip die Folterkammer für die Astronauten auf der Raumstation. Weil man hat auch gemerkt, reines Training, also auf einem Ergometer zum Beispiel, was reines Muskeltraining ist und Herz-Kreislauf-Training ist, also Fahrradfahren und so, zum Beispiel, ist oder auch selbst auf der Treadmill, auf einem Laufband, ist nicht ausreichend für zum Beispiel für den Knochen. Stimulanz braucht Impact. Das heißt, wir haben auch für das Laufband ein Subject Load Device gemacht, also ein wirklich aktives Bungie, im Prinzip, die den Astronauten aktiv auf das Laufband ziehen, sodass bei jedem Schritt, den er macht, ein entsprechender Impact ist, aber nicht nur so passiv wie ein Bungie machen würde, sondern wir messen dabei auch den Impact und die Pace und alles, was damit zusammenhängt. Das ist also teilweise eine relativ ausgefuchste Geschichte. Natürlich, was dann wichtig ist, für eine interplanetare Immersion, zum Beispiel Flug zum Mars, wird man keine Monstergeräte an Bord haben können. Dort braucht man natürlich relativ smarte, kompakte Geräte, also zum Beispiel ein Flywheel-Exercise-Beweis oder so, das im Prinzip den Bedürfnissen dort Rechnung trägt. Aber dafür muss man verstanden haben, auf was kommt es an.
Dass man genau das bauen kann, was am meisten Effizienz hat.
Daher gibt es auch viele verschiedene Experimente mit verschiedenen Geräten, um das erst einmal herauszufinden, was jetzt wirklich essenziell ist. Oder was mehr ein Ice-to-Half ist.
Dazu muss man erstmal so ein Fitnesscenter da oben aufbauen, um zu gucken, was am besten funktioniert.
Ja, und natürlich smart ist auch, wenn man diese wissenschaftlichen Experimente mit der sowieso nötigen täglichen Übung der Astronauten verbinden kann. Rein von der Crew-Zeit her, weil während diesen eineinhalb oder bis zu zwei Stunden, die die pro Tag trainieren, ist es natürlich smart, wenn man dort ein wissenschaftliches Experiment ihrem Trainingsprogramm praktisch draufsetzen kann.
Ja, dass man das gleich miteinander verbindet.
Und damit natürlich die Crew-Zeit deutlich strecken kann. Und vielleicht auch das Interesse der Astronauten erwecken kann, das ist nicht nur eine stupide 1,5 Stunden Laufband oder Algometer, sondern es fällt wissenschaftlich auch was dabei ab.
Ja, die sind manchmal nicht zu beneiden da. Also permanent so die kleine Versuchsmaus zu sein, sozusagen da oben und allem ausgesetzt zu sein. Aber naja, die haben sich das ja auch nicht anders ausgesucht.
Das ist richtig, die machen das mit großer Disziplin. Und sie werden natürlich vorher entsprechend gebrieft. Und sie sind ganz frei, sich zum einen Experimente auszuschließen, die sie nicht machen wollen. Oder auch im positiven Sinne zu akzeptieren. Und auch jederzeit wieder auszusteigen, wenn sie aus irgendwelchen Gründen der Meinung sind, das geht nicht mehr oder das tut mir nicht gut.
Ich hatte ja hier auch im ERC, jetzt hab ich schon wieder ein paar Sendungen gefunden, ob die ich mal verweisen kann, Ausgabe 11 mit Samantha Christopheretti gesprochen, die ja viel erzählt hat hier über ihre Ausbildung zur Astronautin, die ja mittlerweile auch für eine Mission schon ausgewählt worden ist.
Ich glaube, 2014 wird sie fliegen, für auch die üblichen 5,5 Monate ungefähr.
Voraus geht jetzt noch Alexander Gerst an Bord, nach langer Zeit mal wieder ein deutscher Astronaut. Mit Samantha hatte ich aber gesprochen und ich war dann auch zufällig im Parabelflug, dann ein paar Monate später mit ihr gemeinsam an Bord, wo sie auch sagte, das ist für sie auch sehr wichtig, als Astronautin hier auch diesen Kontakt mit den Wissenschaftlern zu haben und auch wirklich mal live dabei zu sein, wenn die so ihre ganzen Experimente ja im Prinzip aktiv einsetzen, vorbereiten. Und teilweise sind ja auch gerade die Experimente, die auf den Parabelflug geflogen werden, dann nicht selten auch Kandidaten für die ISS.
Viele von diesen Experimenten auch im medizinischen Bereich werden natürlich auf Parabelflügen getestet. Der medizinische Experimenteffekt ist dort oft nicht so sehr ausgeprägt, weil einfach die Phase mit den 20 Sekunden, mit der reduzierten Schwerkraft dort sehr kurz ist letztendlich. Aber rein vom Händlingen oder so oder von gewissen sensorischen Aspekten sind natürlich Parabelflüge gerade für diese Experimente ganz ausgezeichnet. Und gleichzeitig natürlich und deswegen fliegen wir auch oft unsere Astronauten auf den Parabelflügen. Sie haben dort den direkten Kontakt mit den Wissenschaftlern. Aber sie können natürlich gewisse Experimente auch vom Instrumentarium einfach ausprobieren unter relativ relevanten Bedingungen. Also natürlich kurzzeitig, wissenschaftlich vielleicht nicht so relevant, aber mehr vom operationellen Her, letztendlich. Um auch zu sehen, wo es darauf ankommt und natürlich auch rechtzeitig noch entsprechendes Feedback zu geben, was man anders besser machen könnte oder was ihnen vielleicht missfällt, unbehagenbereitet gar oder andere Dinge.
Jetzt haben wir viel gesprochen über biologische Experimente. Die Physik spielt ja auch noch eine Rolle. Und da meinst du ja besonders die Fundamentalfysik, also wirklich so die Forschung, um die Forschung willen. Gab es denn eigentlich schon irgendwelche Forschungen, die auf der ISS durchgeführt wurden, die auch jetzt schon mittelfristig interessante Ergebnisse über die Forschung selbst hinaus gebracht haben?
Von der Physik her ist es so, wir haben die Materialwissenschaft mit dem Start von dem Material Science Labor 2010 begonnen. Das wurde in einer Partnerschaft mit einem Abkommen mit der NASA gemacht. Das Material Science Lab ist auch im Destiny Lab Labor von der NASA und wird dort über dieses Agreement mit NASA Ressourcen betrieben. Hier werden im Wesentlichen Erstarrungsvorgänge in Legierungen, in den industriell relevanten Legierungen, gemessen. Das heißt, Materialproben nach einem gewissen thermischen Muster aufgeschmolzen und entsprechend abgekühlt, um gewisse Gefügeneigenschaften zu erreichen von der Struktur und natürlich damit auch von der Festigkeit und insgesamt den Materialeigenschaften dieser Legierungen, die für verschiedene Anwendungen in den letzten Jahren auch relevant sind. Komplementär dazu wird im nächsten Jahr der sogenannte Electromagnetic Levitator fliegen. Das ist also eine Anlage, wo man metallische Proben in der Schwebe halten kann und dort im geschmolzenen Zustand die Materialeigenschaften sehr präzise, berührungslos messen kann.
Das heißt also ein Magnetfeld hält sie dann sozusagen in der Luft, während sie heiß sind.
Genau, ein Magnetfeld hält sie in der Luft. Das ist das eine. Das ist keine Luft, das ist entweder evakuiert oder mit Argon, also mit einem Edelgas gefüllt, um auch natürlich Oxidation an der Oberfläche von diesen Metallischen Flüssigkeitstropfen auszuschließen. Und zum zweiten macht diese Spule, diese Magnetspule sorgt auch für die Aufheizung der Proben. Das heißt also, sie hat letzten Endes einen doppelten Zweck. Und damit kann man Proben bis zu ca. 2200 Grad prozessieren. Und in dem ganzen Temperaturbereich auch ihre Theirthermophysikalischen Eigenschaften sehr präzise messen, die sehr viel präziser sind, als man es auf der Erde machen kann, wo man natürlich dafür einen Tegel braucht. Und dort natürlich sehr viel Interaktion mit den Tegel-Eigenschaften, auch von den Obenflächenspannungen, von der Benetzung und all diesen Dingen. Und auch von Verunreidungen her natürlich hat. Und all diese Daten werden vor allem für die Gießereitechnik benötigt, um daraus entsprechend optimale Materialien herzustellen. Diese Anlage wurde auch schon auf SpaceLab damals geflogen, natürlich immer noch mit einer sehr begrenzten Anzahl von Proben. Auch Höhenforschungsraketen, auch man kann mit Mühe zwei Proben mit einem Temperaturparameter in den sechs Minuten prozessieren. Und hier geht es natürlich dann im Prinzip über Wochen und Monate, wo man sehr, sehr viele verschiedene Temperaturstufen machen kann oder auf Heiz-Abkühl-Zyklen. Man sieht dabei, dass man die Proben sehr weit unterkühlen kann, also deutlich unter ihren Schmelzpunkt. Und sie aber durch die Bührung, nachdem sie mit nichts Kontakt haben, noch nicht erstarrt sind. Das ist also so ein metastabiles Gebiet im Prinzip, dass natürlich durchaus im Inneren einer Schmelze, wo also die Schmelze keinen direkten Wandkontakt, genauso passieren kann. Wo wirklich nur Flüssig-Flüssig-Kontakt letztendlich ist. Und hier kann man sehr, sehr wichtige Parameter ermitteln. Und die wirklich auch im industriellen Bereich für Materialien, also bekannte und neue Materialien, entsprechend einsetzen.
Heißt das, dass auf der ISS nur so langfristige Experimente zum Einsatz kommen?
Ich würde es jetzt nicht unbedingt nur langfristige Experimente geben. Ich nenne jetzt mal einfach ein sehr langfristiges Experiment. Das ist zum Beispiel die Solar-Payload. Das ist also eine Payload mit anfangs drei, im Moment werden noch zwei von den Spektrometer betrieben, die den ganzen Sonnenzyklus messen, verfolgen. Seit 2008, das war ungefähr das relative Minimum. In diesem und teilweise Ende letzten Jahres ist das Maximum. Und das Minimum wird wieder 2016 erreicht. Das ist also im Prinzip ein Zehn-Jahres-Experiment, wo ein kontinuierliches Monitoring gemacht wird.
Ja, der Sonnenaktivität.
Der Sonnenaktivität oder Matroschka, wie vorhin gesagt, wo man über Monate und Jahre hinweg die kosmische Strahlung misst. In vielen anderen Fällen ist es mehr so in der Physik, dass man sehr, sehr viele Parameter hat. Das heißt, in der Fluidphysik sehr viele, meinetwegen Temperatur oder andere Manipulationsparameter, wo man dann im Prinzip ein ganzes Modell bauen kann. Das geophysikalische Strömungsexperiment ist jetzt vor nach zweieinhalb Jahren Betrieb, insgesamt Betriebsdauer, zu Ende gekommen. Oder ein thermokapillares Strömungsexperiment, das auf der ISS betrieben wird, das für die Strömungen in Tanks zuständig ist. Rein oberflächenspannungsgetriebene Strömungen, wo man sehr viele Parameter, letztendlich eine Einstellung kann, Strömungsgeschwindigkeiten, Füllgrad von so einer kapillaren V-förmigen Rinne oder so, die diesen Treibstoff letztendlich zum Auslass von diesem Tank führt, um diese Tanks auch ohne Schwerkraft, weil die Flüssigkeit ist natürlich irgendwo an der Wand oder so. Aber man will ja praktisch die Tanks ganz entleeren oder ganz benutzen, man die gesichert an den richtigen Ort hinbringt.
Und dazu muss man sozusagen solche Experimente immer wieder laufen lassen. Das heißt, die Experimente für sich hatten sehr überschaubaren Zeitraum.
Es sind sehr viele Durchgänge im Prinzip. Mit verschiedenen Einstellungen, mit verschiedenen Strömungsgeschwindigkeiten, mit verschiedenen Temperaturen, wo sich auch die Viskosität ändert und Parametern. Oder in der Materialforschung, für verschiedene Materialien natürlich, verschiedene Temperaturen, viele verschiedene Legierungen. Da war es natürlich dann wirklich ein umfassendes Modell. Und durch die entsprechenden Daten, den es letztendlich ermöglicht, die man dann auch numerisch denn vernünftig verwerten kann. Und nicht nur so punktuelle Modelle, die man durch Einzel-Experimente auf Kurzzeitmissionen hat, wie man es letztendlich auch früher gemacht hat. Und was heute sicherlich auch noch deutlich anders ist, als in früheren Jahren die Experimentiertechnik, vor allem die Diagnostik ist natürlich sehr viel fortschrittlicher, wo man früher nur so global mit einer Videokamera vielleicht beobachtet hat, oder eine Temperatur lokal irgendwo gemessen hat, macht man dies heutzutage mit Interfermen, mit berührungsloser Messtechnik. Und natürlich auch mit ganz anderen Datenraten, als früher letztendlich möglich von der Telemetrie her.
Das heißt für diese permanente Wiederholung ist es auch langfristig. Aber so richtig so Kurzzeitexperimente in dem Sinne haben da nichts zu suchen?
Es gibt einige Kurzzeitexperimente aus guten Gründen. Es ist zwar manchmal von der Experimentlogistik nicht ganz einfach, aber diese sind vor allem in der Biologie, wo manche Prozesse eher im Bereich von Tagen ablaufen. Das sind auch mehr die Experimente, die früher gut mit Spacelab-Missionen, also mit ein, zwei Wochen Missionen kompatibel waren.
Die gibt es jetzt sozusagen gar nicht mehr, diese mehrtägigen...
Ja, von den Randbedingungen ist es schwierig. Wir haben früher einige oder viele von diesen Experimenten während der sogenannten Soyuz-Taxiflüge gemacht. zwischen 2003 und 2008, wo einige der ESA-Astronauten auch auf einer 7- bis 10-Tage-Mission geflogen sind, dabei praktisch die Proben mitgenommen haben, mitsamt Inkubator teilweise, und nach ihrer Mission, also nach 7 bis 10 Tagen, auch wieder entsprechend zurückgebracht haben. Dieses Missionsszenario, das natürlich auch bei Shuttle-Missionen möglich war, gleiche Dauer ungefähr, während der Aufbauphase von der Raumstation gibt es im Moment praktisch nicht mehr.
Aber Astronauten werden auch immer noch hochgeschossen.
Ja, aber es ist insofern ein bisschen schwieriger. Man muss natürlich, wo möglich, nach Experimentbeendigung, jetzt im biologischen Bereich zum Beispiel, die Proben konditionieren, man tut sie in den Fräser rein, also friert sie ein im Prinzip und bringt sie dann letztendlich erst zurück. Oder, das ist auch natürlich eine Methode, man macht zum Beispiel eine Mission SpaceX, ist normalerweise dockt für vier Wochen ungefähr an und bringt die praktisch hoch, prozessiert die Proben, konditioniert sie gegebenenfalls und bringt sie dann nach relativ kurzer Zeit wieder zurück. Oder wie jetzt, gut, das ist nur eine einmalige Aktion.
Also mit SpaceX ist das das Dragon-Raumschiff, das Versorgungsmodul.
Genau, also auch ein Cargo-Raumschiff, aber mit Rückführmöglichkeit, konditionierter Rückführmöglichkeit, sogar für Proben, wo man dies letztendlich nicht so machen kann. Mit Soyuz ist es leider momentan nicht möglich. Das heißt, es ist immer die Hälfte der Besatzung, das heißt drei Besatzungsmitglieder kommen zurück und zwei Wochen später kommt aus der neue Soyuz-Besatzung. Wenn es umgekehrt herum wäre, wenn erst die neue Besatzung käme und dann erst die alte geht, wäre es ideal.
Und so war das mal, oder?
So war das. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Direct und Indirect Crew Handover. Früher war es Direct, da sind erst die neuen gekommen und die alten gegangen, sonst wäre 14 Tage gegangen mit mir. Das hat im Prinzip auch logistische Gründe, weil während einer gewissen Zeit hätte man sonst neun Crew-Members auf der ISS, was auch von der Klimaanlage nicht unbedingt kompatibel ist. Die ist für sechs oder sieben ausgelegt. Und natürlich auch von der generellen Unterbringung der Crew.
Ich habe ja so eine Lieblingswebseite, die heißt howmanypeopleareinspacerightnow.com. Da steht jetzt sechs. Mehr werden es auch erst mal nicht.
Mehr werden es vorerst nicht. Es werden im Herbst 2015 mal kurzfristig neun werden, wo ein sehr spezielles Missionsszenario stattfindet. Und das heißt, das kommt daher, weil im Frühjahr 2015 wird eine Langzeitmission gestartet. Also eine lange Langzeitmission. Das heißt, zwei Crew-Members, ein amerikanischer Astronaut und ein russischer Kosmonaut, werden ein Jahr auf der ISS bleiben und nicht nur diese 5,5 oder 6 Monate üblicherweise. Das heißt, nach der Hälfte ihrer Zeit fällt natürlich ein Austauschzyklus aus. Und dort wird praktisch nur das Soyuz-Vehikel ausgetauscht. Und da kommt tatsächlich noch mal ein russischer Kommandant mit einem neuen Soyuz an. Und es fliegen zwei Astronauten mit, die also nach diesen zehn Tagen ungefähr von der Dockingperiode wieder mit zurückkommen. Während diese zwei speziellen Astronauten erst nach einem Jahr, das heißt wieder im Frühjahr 2016, letzten Endes zurückkommen.
Ich finde das schon immer so ein bisschen bedrückend, dass die Menschheit gerade mal ein Milliardstel seiner Bevölkerung irgendwie in einem Orbit vorzuhalten. Da müsste doch eigentlich mehr drin sein.
Das ist sicher richtig, ja. Und dann ab 2017 ungefähr, also als größten Ordnungs, wenn die NASA dann wieder in der Lage sein wird, mit einem eigenen Q-Transportvehikel zu fliegen, dann wird es permanent sieben Astronauten auf der ISS geben. Das heißt, dieses Vehikel wird dann vier Astronauten transportieren, Astronauten, Kosmonauten transportieren können.
Welche Bedeutung hat denn jetzt die ISS so insgesamt für die Forschung als solche? Also wenn man das jetzt mal sozusagen auch jenen, wenn man sozusagen mal Forschung als solche, es wird ja auch viel Forschung natürlich nach wie vor auf den Boden gemacht, ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt nur noch ohne Gravitation Dinge vorantreiben könnte. Es gibt eben nur spezifische Bereiche, da ist es eben sehr wünschenswert bis absolut notwendig, so etwas wie die ISS zum Einsatz zu bringen. Wir wissen, es gibt auch noch andere schwere Losigkeitsoptionen so auf der Erde. Aber kann man das irgendwie auf so einen Nenner bringen, was so die Bedeutung des ganzen Forschungsapparats da oben ist?
Ich denke, man muss eines ganz klar sein, die meisten Experimente, die auf der Raumstation prozessiert werden, das sind keine reinen Raumfahrt-Experimente, keine reinen Space-Experimente. Die haben eine sehr, sehr lange Historie schon auf der Erde, wo sie vorbereitet werden, wo die wissenschaftliche Forschungsstellung, Forschungsproblematik mit den irrtischen Möglichkeiten so weit getrieben wird, wie sie dort getrieben werden kann und wo praktisch mehr oder minder als letzter oder vorletzter Schritt die Space-Parameter dann manipuliert werden. Das heißt, entweder die Schwerkraft eliminiert wird oder die kosmische Strahlung hinzugeführt wird oder eine Kombination aus mehreren Aspekten mit Vakuum, wenn etwas außerhalb der Raumstation betrieben wird. Oder meinetwegen jetzt bei den Atomuhren, wo die halt von der Physik her die Raumstation brauchen, durch die Schwerelosigkeit, aber gleichzeitig auch die Kommunikation mit erdgebundenen Hochpräzisionsuhren in verschiedenen Laboratorien auf der ganzen Welt. Insofern ist es ganz wichtig, dass die Raumstationsforschung in den meisten Fällen sehr eng mit einer bodengebundenen Forschung oder auf eine bodengebundene Forschung aufsetzt, von der Fragestellung, mit der auch genau genommen verbunden bleibt, dass man nicht so singuläre Raumfahrtexperimente hat. Manche sind so. Da gibt es auf der Erde nichts zu forschen, weil die Randbedingungen nicht gegeben sind. Aber die meisten sind sehr stark damit verbunden. Wir haben auch einige Experimente mit der Europäischen Kommission, mit dem FP7-Programm, also dem Forschungsrahmenprogramm 7, wo sehr viel Industrie involviert ist und wo wir einige der Parameter, vor allem im Legierungsbereich, auf der Raumstation den letzten Endes testen. Und die Möglichkeiten im Weltraum mit den ganzen erdgebundenen Möglichkeiten optimal kombinieren und damit auch eine optimale Synergie, aber natürlich auch Verbreitung der wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse im industriellen Bereich realisieren können. Endlich ist es letztendlich auch in der Biotechnologie, wo man gewisse Dinge, grundsätzliche Fragestellungen hat, aber wo natürlich entsprechende Firmen auch daran interessiert sind, wie läuft dies ab, was, wie kann man gewisse Dinge manipulieren. Und also langer Rede, kurzer Sinn, es ist oftmals sehr wichtig, einfach diesen engen Link zu behalten. Und vielleicht an dieser Stelle möchte ich eine kurze Bezug zu einer Aussage von Kanzlerin Merkel geben, die sie zweimal getätigt hat. Sie ist ja auch Physikerin und war mehr in der Grundlagenphysik beschäftigt. Sie sagte, ok, zum einen, ok, Wissenschaft braucht Zeit, da kann man nicht drängeln und sagen, in einem oder zwei Jahren muss das Ergebnis auf den Tisch legen. Und genau dieses Ergebnis, weil wir wissen es oft nicht, was dabei rauskommt. Das mag unsere Thesen bestätigen oder widerlegen oder was ganz Neues sein, dass wir am Ende mehr neue Fragen haben, als wir jemals gedacht haben oder als wir beantworten konnten mit diesem Experiment. Und zum Zweiten die andere Aussage, man sollte nicht immer fragen, für was ist es gut? Wie kann ich im industriellen Wirtschaften in Sinne Profit draus schlagen? Natürlich ist das politisch immer attraktiv. Jede Regierung lebt davon, dass sie von ein paar Jahren Horizont oder so, aber auch da sagt sie, und das ist wirklich unsere Erfahrung. Vieles fängt in der Grundlagenwissenschaft an, wo die Wissenschaftler gewisse grundlegenden Dinge lernen oder Einblicke haben. Und das ist auch das Großartige an der Raumstation. Man hat Zeit. Man kann zwei, drei, vier Iterationen von Experimenten machen. Nicht nur eines. Mit dem ersten versucht man mal, lernt gewisse Dinge und setzt sich neue Ziele, auch im operativen Hinsicht bei der zweiten, dritten, vierten Generation von Experimenten. Oder natürlich ändert auch das wissenschaftliche Team von der Fragestellung her, von der Expertise her und kann natürlich damit relativ weit kommen. Über 10, 15 Jahre hinweg, die ja die Raumstation letztendlich zur Verfügung steht.
Ja, stellt sich natürlich auch noch die Frage, wie lange steht uns eigentlich die Raumstation noch zur Verfügung? Also das Ding wird ja auch älter. Wie lange hält sie denn noch?
Die Raumstation hat also vielleicht zwei Aspekte oder drei Aspekte, die ganz interessant sind. Der technische Aspekte wird im Prinzip von all den Raumstationspartnern, die also dort Elemente oben haben, im Fünf-Jahres-Zyklus im Prinzip untersucht bzw. neu zertifiziert. Auch über die ursprünglich vorgesehene Lebensdauer hinaus. Die letzten Analysen, die von allen Partnern gemacht wurden, haben keinen, auf gut neu, Showstopper gezeigt bis 2028. Es ist natürlich notwendig, gewisse Austauschmaßnahmen vorzunehmen von zeitlimitierten Bauteilen wie Dichtungen oder Pumpen oder solche Dinge, die sich einfach abnutzen mit der Zeit. Aber es gibt auch von den Modulen her keine, wo man sagen kann, ok, da ist das 2015, 20 oder was auch immer, oder nach 15 oder 20 Jahren ist es praktisch nicht mehr betreibbar. Somit gibt es also den technischen Horizont momentan bis 2028. Das heißt nicht, dass er nicht länger sein kann. Er wurde nur nicht darüber hinaus untersucht. Der momentan politische Horizont ist 2020, wobei es im Raumstationsprogramm so ist, bis 2020 haben sich alle ISS-Partner verpflichtet mitzumachen. Damit ist auch die Finanzierung bis 2020 mehr oder minder gesichert. Allerdings ist das Raumstationsprogramm nicht auf einen gewissen Endpunkt festgelegt. Das heißt, es dauert so lange, wie die Partner mitmachen. Das heißt, es ist wirklich open-ended. Wer das Programm beendigen will, muss das aktiv tun. Es gibt kein nominelles Missionsende des Raumstationsprogramms. Insofern gibt es da sehr gute Perspektiven, auch in technischer Hinsicht. Aber auch das wissenschaftliche Programm ist relativ gut fundiert. Wir haben vor allem in Europa sehr viel mehr Bedarf, als wir Ressourcen dafür haben.
Mehr Bedarf an was?
Mehr Forschungsbedarf, deutlich mehr Projekte oder so, die auf der ISS oder die auf die ISS möchten, als wir real mit unseren Ressourcen tatsächlich durchführen können. Insofern ist auch immer unser Bestreben mit anderen Partnern, vor allem USA, Russland, aber natürlich auch mit Japan und Kanada, Kooperationen einzugehen und von dort weitere Ressourcen zu bekommen, einfach um mehr zu machen.
Ist es denn noch vorstellbar, dass die Kapazitäten der ISS noch einmal, weiteres Mal ausgebaut werden? Also in gewisser Hinsicht ist sie ja erstmal fertig. Also das, was ursprünglich geplant war, ist zusammengebaut worden oder fehlt noch irgendwas? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Es wird, sagen wir, der Ausbau im US-Segment ist im Prinzip beendet. Mit dem Ende des Shuttle-Programms wurde, oder auch das Shuttle-Programm wurde so weit geführt, um den Ausbau des US-Teils fertigzustellen. Es werden natürlich immer weitere Experimente ausgetauscht, Ersatzteile hochgebracht und so weiter. Aber nicht die großen Elemente. Auf der anderen Seite, im russischen Segment, gibt es das nächste Modul, das sogenannte MLM. Das ist im Prinzip mehr oder minder baugleich zum Service-Modul. Das soll also ein neues Multipurpose Lab-Modul, dafür steht MLM. Im russischen Segment ist bisher etwas drangvolle Enge. Das ist zum einen von den Anzahl der Modulen nicht so groß wie die anderen Labore. Und natürlich müssen auch die Russen all die On-Board-Storage und so weiter in den eigenen Modulen halten, sodass sie also wirklich jetzt großen Wert darauf legen, ein neues Science-Modul zu haben und endlich auch mal richtig Platz für wissenschaftliche Experimente im großen Stil zu haben. Wobei die Russen dann auch vor allem, wenn die ISS eine Perspektive über 2020 hinaus hat, auch noch planen, weitere Module im russischen Teil der Raumstation anzuflanschen, inklusive auch Solarmodulen, um auch ihre eigene elektrische Power zu generieren. Sie haben auch massiv ihr Telemetriesystem aufgerüstet, also um die Datenübertragung zu optimieren. Hier ist auf der russischen Seite doch noch einiges im Plus, und wird sicher in den nächsten Jahren auch entsprechend noch expandieren.
Da ist sozusagen noch Raum für Erweiterungen vorgesehen und soll auch erweitert werden. Wie viele Science-Module gibt es denn im russischen Teil derzeit? Also dedizierte Science-Module?
Es gibt eigentlich kein dediziertes Science-Modul. Das ist also der große Engpass auf der russischen Seite. Insofern sind sie natürlich bestrebt, das MLM möglichst bald hochzubringen. Also es wäre dann sozusagen das erste Modul, was vollständig ausschließlich der Forschung gewickelt ist. Richtig, das richtige Science-Modul, ganz genau. Wo man wirklich auch Platz hätte und auch eine entsprechende Infrastruktur, die... Obwohl es ein bisschen anders aufgebaut ist, also es werden dort keine ganzen Racks ausgetauscht, sondern es sind mehr so Einbau-Racks, also in die entsprechende Experiment-Eintübe bis zur annähernden Kühlschrankgröße, also nicht Gefrierschrank, sondern Kühlschrank, dann eingebaut werden können. Das ist ein bisschen ein anderes Konzept. Hängt natürlich auch wieder mit dem russischen Hatch zusammen. 70 Zentimeter.
Manchmal gelingt es ja der ISS auch wirklich so in das Bewusstsein einer größeren Öffentlichkeit durchzudringen, obwohl man sich vielleicht häufig nicht so richtig Gedanken darüber macht, dass das Ding da fliegt. Aber man kann es ja tatsächlich regelmäßig sehen, wenn man nur zum richtigen Zeitpunkt an die richtige Stelle schaut, weil so weit weg ist es ja nun dann auch wieder nicht. Was denkt man, wenn man jetzt mit so einem, jetzt komme ich vielleicht ein bisschen populär rüber, aber dieses großartige Musikvideo, was dieser Commander Hetfield aus Kanada gemacht hat, was um die Welt herumging, das hat irgendwie eine Verbindung geschaffen, war mein Eindruck zu diesem Projekt, wie schon lange keine Aktivität mehr vorher. Hat man das gemerkt, wenn man so in diesem ISS-Apparat ist, dass die Wahrnehmung dieses außergewöhnlichen Projektes sich dadurch ändert?
Das ist sicher richtig. Das ist visuell und in dem Fall auch akustisch eine ganz andere Wahrnehmung. Die ist natürlich mehr oder minder auch in Echtzeit. Währenddessen sind viele Experimente sehr lange gedauert, bis man was davon sieht. Auch medizinische Untersuchungen, dann merkt man erst, wenn das Experiment ausgewertet ist, was ist das Resultat. Ähnliche Kategorien, zum Beispiel auch Erdbeobachtungsaspekte über die Crew von oben, wenn sie vor allem über die nächtlichen oder dunklen Teile der Erde fliegt, die beleuchtenden Städte usw. aufnimmt, oder Vulkanausbrüche oder Hurricanes usw. Das sind Dinge, die die Menschheit natürlich auf der Erde irgendwo kennt, aber damit aus einer ganz speziellen, natürlich auch sehr attraktiven Perspektive sieht. Aus einer fotografischen Perspektive, auch natürlich auch filmischen Perspektive, also nicht nur einzelne Bilder, sondern bewegte Bilder. Und dann ist natürlich noch der menschliche Aspekt, der Mensch im Weltraum, lebt dort, arbeitet dort, aber kreiert auch Emotionen von dort, wie es Chris Hadfield mit seinem Song usw.
auch mit seinen Fotos. Ich glaube, er hat mehr Fotomaterial von oben generiert als kaum ein Astronaut oder überhaupt kein Astronaut vorher. Beeindruckendes Material. Und vor allem, ich denke, er war nicht der Erste, also auch Paolo Nespoli vor kurzem, ist auch sehr sichtbar gewesen, fand ich, hat sich da den ganzen Tag über Twitter und andere Kanäle auch mit denen da unten auseinandergesetzt. Und ich dachte mir dabei immer wieder so, ja, vielleicht ist das auch, sagen wir mal, eine Art der Wissenschaft, die an der Stelle verstärkt werden sollte, dass man eben schaut, ob man nicht mit dieser Öffentlichkeit, mit dieser aufmerksamen Öffentlichkeit eben auch getragen durch das Internet, nicht vielleicht in zunehmendem Maße sich mal Projekte ausdenken sollte, die quasi auch die Beteiligung dieser Öffentlichkeit, also die unmittelbare Beteiligung dieser Öffentlichkeit in irgendeiner Form mit einschließt. Dass das sozusagen nicht nur so ein Platz für Wissenschaftler ist, sondern quasi auch ein Spielplatz für die Menschheit als solche.
Das ist sicher ein wichtiger und interessanter Aspekt. Vielleicht auch in diesem Bereich. Es wird vielleicht schwierig sein, zumindest viele Experimente zu finden, die diesen Kriterien irgendwie genügen. Dass dies in guter Sichtbarkeit, Verständlichkeit und auch in angemessener Zeit abläuft. Weil viele von den Experimenten dauern einfach viel zu lange. Die müsste man dann im Nachhinein wieder in Zeitrafforter irgendwie zusammensetzen, wie sich einzelne Zellen verändern oder wie sich Fluide bewegen oder so. Und dann ist es vielleicht immer noch für viele Leute schwierig zu verstehen, was ist das, was soll das, was sehe ich da? Ich denke, in diesem Zusammenhang ist es ganz wichtig und visuell attraktiv, die gewissen Demonstrationsexperimente, die die Astronauten machen, auch für die jüngere Generation, für die Schüler und so weiter, relativ einfache Experimente, wo sie physikalische Effekte demonstrieren, die durch Schwerelosigkeit, durch Kombination von schwachen Kräften, die dann letztendlich noch übrig bleiben, dort zutage treten oder nicht mehr zutage treten. Dinge, die man auf der Erde einfach so erwartet, und dann ist man da oben und dann ist es nicht mehr. Und ich glaube, diese Dinge sind sehr, sehr attraktiv. Auch 3D-Aspekte, also dreidimensionale Aspekte in der Raumstation, außerhalb der Raumstation oder Beobachtung von der Raumstation, von solchen Dingen ist sehr schön. Aber auch im klimatologischen Bereich oder bis hin zum Erdbeobachtungsbereich, glaube ich, kann man da ganz interessante Effekte haben. Zum Beispiel, wir bereiten eine Nutzlast vor, die 2016 fliegen wird, die sich mit dem Bereich, also in der oberen Atmosphäre beschäftigt, wo teilweise enorme Entladungen stattfinden. Also das gute Gewitter, das wir auf der Erde sehen, aber natürlich eher in großen Höhen. Und die denn solche Dinge letztendlich auch registrieren. Das ist natürlich sicher auch dann visuell wieder interessant und auch sehr, sehr transient von der Darstellung her.
Vielleicht sollte man mal in dem Research Announcement auch noch mal explizit ein Projekt ausloben, was so eben diese Verbundenheit maximal fördert. Sozusagen als weiteres oder einzelnes Kriterium, was dann auch noch mal zum Einsatz kommen kann.
Absolut, auch dies ist immer absolut willkommen. Wir haben auch ein Experiment, das war in der letzten lebenswissenschaftlichen Ausschreibung das höchstrangige von der Punktzahl her, das sich mit dem Zug oder mit der Migration von Zugvögeln beschäftigt, die also praktisch global hier unterwegs sind, sodass man mit sehr kleinen Transmittern an den Vögeln und also nicht nur an ein paar Vögeln, sondern Jahrhunderten und Tausenden den globalen Vogelzug von der ISS ausregistriert. Also der Transmitter sitzt auf dem Vogel, auf dem einzelnen Vogel. Der Receiver auf der ISS muss natürlich ein sehr guter Receiver sein, weil der Vogel kann nur eine sehr kleine Batterie tragen und eine sehr kleine Sendeleistung, sodass man dort auch die globale Vogelwanderung oder Migration von der ISS beobachten kann. Was ähnlich ist, wie wir seit nunmehr drei Jahren mit auch Schiffen machen. Das sogenannte Automatic Identification System. Das ist also nichts wissenschaftliches in dem Sinne, mehr so eine technologische Anwendung, auch im operationellen Sinne, wo man den Schiffsverkehr praktisch auf den Weltmeeren registrieren kann. Die Schiffe haben einen Transponder jeweils, mit einer gewissen Kennung natürlich. Und auf der ISS, man sieht es auch auf manchen Bilder, es ist eine kleine, stapförmige Antenne. Und innen ein Receiver, und die schickt dann praktisch die Daten über die Telemetrie.
Das heißt, da wird sozusagen so ausgenutzt, dass die ISS auf so relativ niedriger Höhe, permanent mit hoher Geschwindigkeit, eigentlich zumindest so in diesen Mittelstreifen.
Und da spielt auch das eine Kriterium keine Rolle, dass die ISS nicht über die Pole fliegt von ihrem Orbit, weil auf dem Pro-Bereich fahren wenig Schiffe. Insofern geht einem da nichts ab. Und dies kann man dann letztendlich auch mit erdgebundenen Daten kombinieren, weil natürlich entlang der ganzen Meeresküsten ähnliche Systeme stehen, aber die natürlich auch durch die Erdkrümung nur 60 bis 100 Kilometer weit rausreichen. Und jetzt in Zukunft wird es natürlich auch zunehmend satellitengebundene Systeme geben für den gleichen Zweck.
Jetzt fällt mir dann doch tatsächlich zum Schluss auch nochmal eine Sendung ein, auf die ich verweisen kann. Und zwar aus einem bestimmten Grund. Envisat, dieser große Satellit, der ja leider nicht mehr funktioniert, soll ja künftig dann ersetzt werden durch eine größere Armada, ein neuer Satellit, das GMES-Programm, sehr breit aufgestellt, was halt Sicherheit und Erdbeobachtunganwendungen hat. Und dabei kam auch zur Sprache, dass eben ein Großteil dieser Daten, nicht sogar alle, ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr so genau, offen zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Dass man sozusagen wirklich anfängt, einfach mal allen diese Daten bereitzustellen, um sie auswerten zu können. Wie ist denn das mit diesem Informationsfluss der Ergebnisse auf der ISS?
Das ist jetzt mal rein formal betrachtet. Die Daten gehören ein Jahr lang dem jeweiligen Wissenschaftsteam.
Zur Auswertung.
Das Team kann nur eine Person sein, das können auch teilweise bis zu 20, 30 Mitglieder von einem wissenschaftlichen Projekt sein, zur Auswertung und zur Publikation. Danach sind nach diesem einen Jahr die Daten im Prinzip öffentlich. Das heißt, sie sind allen Wissenschaftlern zugänglich. Es ist natürlich oft so, dass sich die Wissenschaftler zusammen oder miteinander ins Benehmen setzen sollten, weil Rohdaten ohne Kalibrierung usw. sind zu nicht viel zu gebrauchen. Also dass eine gewissenschaftliche Kooperation einfach nötig ist, um dies zu machen. Aber natürlich werden auch die entsprechenden Publikationen dann wieder als Basis für weiterführende Experimente oder Experimentziele benutzt, um Ähnliches oder anderes im wissenschaftlichen Sinne zu untersuchen. Wenn wir internationale Kooperationen haben, also auch über ESA-Mitgliedsländer hinaus, stehen natürlich die Daten auch international den anderen Partnern genauso uneingeschränkt zur Verfügung. Die wissenschaftliche Welt an sich ist da sowieso sehr liberal. Also sehr viel liberaler als die Formalien, die es möglicherweise erlauben.
Ja, Martin, haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges ausgelassen, das du gerne noch hiermit auf den Weg geben möchtest?
Ich denke, die Raumstation, man muss dies wirklich als ein permanentes Labor mit speziellen Randbedingungen betrachten, wo man sehr viel tun kann. Natürlich auch manche Dinge nicht ganz so elegant tun kann oder mit gewissen Schwierigkeiten verbunden sind im Vergleich mit dem Laborbetrieb. Dies muss man sicherlich berücksichtigen. Ich denke, was auch sehr wichtig ist, ist, die internationale Kooperation hat gezeigt, dass ganz verschiedene Technologien, verschiedene Systeme, prinzipiell verschiedene Schnittstellen miteinander korrespondieren, kommunizieren, funktionieren können über viele Jahre. Diese internationale Partnerschaft hat auch gezeigt, und ich denke, das ist ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt, auch politisch und programmatisch, dass in schwierigen Zeiten, also nicht nur technisch schwierigen Zeiten, wie nach dem Shuttle-Absturz oder so, aber auch in finanziellen schwierigen Zeiten in einzelnen Ländern, die globale Partnerschaft dieses multinationale, globale Projekt am Laufen da hält, durch die Verpflichtung zum einen. Und es will eigentlich keiner aussteigen. Und man sagt dann, okay, wir haben aber die Partnerschaft. Wir haben eigentlich beschlossen, dass wir bis auf Weiteres, und es gibt ja kein nominelles Ende der Raumstation, dieses globale Projekt weiterführen. Und ich denke, es gibt noch sehr, sehr viel zum Forschen im Grundlagenforschungsbereich, im Anwendungsforschungsbereich. Die Raumstation, viele von den Experimenten, vor allem im lebenswissenschaftlichen, aber durchaus auch teilweise im physikalischen Bereich, technologischen Bereich, auch Lebenserhaltungssysteme, dienen der Vorbereitung von der bemannten Exploration des Weltraums auch über den Low Earth Orbit hinaus. Das ist zwar, wie man sieht, nicht ganz einfach, im erdnahen Orbit und wie du auch vorhin gesagt hast, das ist ja etwas mager vielleicht, wenn man nur eine sehr, sehr limitierte Anzahl von Menschen mit sehr großem Aufwand, der dort im All halten kann. Das heißt, wir müssen sehr viel noch lernen, in technischer Hinsicht, in operationeller Hinsicht. Auch die ganzen Schwierigkeiten auf der Raumstation wurden teilweise oder größtenteils gemeinsam gemeistert. Die Russen haben einen wunderbaren Logistik-Service gemacht in den Zeiten, in denen Shuttle nicht fliegen konnte. Man sieht, man kann sehr viel modulieren von den Ressourcen her, entsprechend den jeweiligen Randbedingungen. Ich glaube, das ist eine sehr, sehr wichtige politische, technische und auch humanitäre Aufgabe und auch Sinn und Zweck der Raumstation, all diese Dinge, all diese Aspekte wirklich in der Realität zu zeigen und abzudenken und wie man damit letztendlich auch umgeht. Für zukünftige große Projekte, große Projekte, kleine Projekte. Also ich denke, dieses Projekt hat gezeigt, was es zu leisten im Stande ist. Und das wird sicher auch noch viele Jahre im Stande sein. Ich denke, es wird auch interessant werden, sicher auch manchmal in diesen Stellen etwas problematisch, wenn mal die Raumstation in die Jahre kommen wird, wenn man darüber befinden wird, wie lange macht es noch Sinn zu betreiben? Das wird sicher weit jenseits von 2020 sein. Und was macht man letztendlich danach? Aber bis dahin, denke ich, haben einige Generationen von Forschern noch, aber auch von den Technikern, vielfältige Möglichkeiten, sich dort zu betätigen. Und ich glaube, man kann auch wirklich sagen, Europa war dort seit jeher sehr, sehr aktiv. Auf der technischen Seite, aber auch vor allem im wissenschaftlichen Bereich. Wir haben nie irgendwelche dogmatischen Einschränkungen gehabt. Nur explorationsbezogene Forschung ist gut oder wertvoll. Und alles andere, Physik wie die NASA, braucht man nicht. Inzwischen ist die NASA wieder voll auf unserer Seite. Sie ist in der Physik zurück, in der Materialwissenschaft. Wir haben wunderbare Kooperationen. Und ich denke, so ist dieses Großprojekt, ich möchte es fast so sagen, von unschätzbarem Wert. Insofern sollte man auch nicht gar zu sehr immer nur über die Kosten diskutieren, die natürlich ein wesentlicher Faktor sind. Aber ich glaube, dass all diese Benefits, die daraus sind, springen aus der Raumstation. Alles, was man lernen kann und rausbekommt, dies sicherlich aufwiegt. Und man nicht immer die Frage stellt, oder die Frage stellt, sondern ist es das wert? Oder wie viel kostet dies, wenn ich dies daraus finden will, jetzt nice.
Ja, Martin, schöne Worte zum Abschluss. Ich denke, damit haben wir es dann auch hier zusammengebracht. Vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zur Forschung in und um die ISS herum. Und wenn ihr interessante Ideen habt, was da auch nochmal geforscht werden soll, demnächst gibt es dann wieder eine Ausschreibung. Vielleicht fällt euch ja was ein. Ich sag danke.